I know you guys are banging into your
coffee
and we're live.
You're jumping into swamps and English
royalties.
Homes
like to be introduced together.
You can get very careful when you get
into those sort of predicament in
beheading around every corner when she
messed with the royal family's private
swamps,
especially if you're doing it for some
sort of a psychedelic purpose.
You're trying to elevate yourself by
freezing yourself in there.
Cold,
swampy waters,
freeing yourself.
If you're embarking on a journey of
personal shamanism on royal territory.
Yeah,
yeah.
Your life's in your hands.
Your life could shrivel up as quickly as
my sex organs did in that particular
predicament.
It's definitely an added element.
The ads,
you have to consider it.
It's not a place to go for pride,
but as soon as I like,
yeah,
as soon as I was sort of submerged in
it,
that's what those.
Because even that is just the.
In this case,
just an example of me,
a man simply jumping into cold lake and
I do have a tendency to over poeticize
the mundane experiences of me everyday
life,
but why not?
What else are we going to do while were
in a.
It did make me think.
We are living on narrow lines,
narrow train tracks of existence,
never to have hurt myself,
got
animal nor capable of.
That's that sort of almost like an anti
orgasm like a negative repeat with you
would before what you said before you
got on camera,
how it represents the subconscious and
that going into the murky depths.
That main role is is in fairy stories,
myths and religion person,
if you're not already,
you reckon you'd world love is it?
Or an American scholar called Joseph
Campbell who was a cultural
anthropologist and he studied various
religions and folk towels and found
Corolla and comparisons and
consistencies and and sort of said that
where there are consistencies,
there's true.
If there's some Icelandic myth and it's
telling basically at the same story,
some African story of some native
American story or some daft Celtic folk
tale.
Why are human beings dislocated all over
the world,
coming up the same stories,
coming up the same experiences?
Well,
often in these stories,
the forest is used as the unconscious,
not only the forest represents the
unconscious,
often in mythology,
and you know when a character has to go
into the woods,
that means you've got to go into
yourself,
you're gonna have to go into new
territory and also under the water.
Similarly also represents
unconsciousness and will interest in
baton.
All.
Joe Is like not only ancient mythologies
and old stories,
but also personal dreams.
If you yourself have a drug like this is
where the work of Joseph Campbell in sex
with a worker,
Carl young dude,
he like.
He noticed that people in their personal
myths that drives your cameras,
said dreams are private myths.
Myths are public dreams in people's
personal dreams.
They come up with images,
archetypes and stories that can also be
found in fairy tales.
You know,
just someone asleep.
I,
Oh,
I was just walking and I went into the
woods and I met this old woman in the
woods and she told me that everything
was going to be okay,
and then she put up a hood and winch
took a hood down again.
It was my mother's face.
He's like,
people are inventing their own myths
like that because of course all culture
is created by consciousness,
so on some level it's in us.
It's in US individually.
Yeah.
Joseph Campbell's work is amazing and
when you do look at all the different
stories and how they coincide and how,
how many similarities they share,
it is really interesting to see what are
people trying to accomplish with these
archetypes,
like what are they trying to sort out
because it seems like that has to be
some things.
Lessons passed down to children than to
pass down to other people so they can
learn things without having to
experience the woods themselves.
But then there's also some sort of
archetypes that they're sort of defining
the reality around them in a very
similar way all over the world.
I suppose what I record joe is the more
diverse our culture,
but like know it's weird isn't because
we don't want to live with globalization
and homogenization were cultural.
Corporatism is coming uniform for our
world,
but also there are many,
many,
many disparate experiences,
but on some level as human beings,
if we are anatomically as similar as we
are,
perhaps it's safe to assume that we're
psychologically comparatively similar
like you know,
even though you and I also so different
body types or whatever and look sort of
at a glance kind of dealing with both.
Ultimately you've got the same organs
with running in pretty much the same way
or perhaps we have the same
psychological Palette,
so throughout the world people are.
Everyone's having a very similar
experience of being human.
The anxiety of not being good enough,
the fear of death,
constantly looking for something in the
outside world that's gonna solve the
problems that's going to answer your
questions and like in a lot of these
ancient texts that I've mostly got at
fruit,
Joseph Campbell or you know,
Hinduism for beginners,
that's normally my entry point.
I like Uma auto didact,
self taught person.
That's one of the things I love about
your podcast is that can you can hear
you.
This is a person educated themselves and
continuing to educate themselves through
life.
Well,
like one of the things that are picked
up in that.
It's like the Indian very,
very ancient texts.
There are people that the same way as in
our,
like in our our time that's defined by
science and technology.
There were times where people define
themselves through meditation and
experiences in income,
in consciousness.
Like those people that wrote say the
upanishads,
whoever the hell they were.
These ratios,
these ancient Indian yogis that when
into deep,
deep meditative states and came back
with mantras and truves.
Those people are as diligent and as
fastidious as a scientist in a
laboratory that comes back and goes,
well look,
we've,
you know,
we've broke down,
Watson and Crick break it down the DNA.
They come back and go,
this is what it is to be human.
You are going to die.
You need to get.
You need to come to terms with the
relationship between your contract sale
for new material self.
That's the.
For me,
that's the stuff like that's the
conversation that I'm into and that's
why whenever I find it,
wherever it comes from Joseph Campbell
or young or even checking out this
podcast,
like a lot of stuff can hancock Graham
in Cox into that.
Always a pressie something deep in me.
That's why I'm always looking for,
you know,
Joe,
the moment we think that shutter you get
there's truth in there,
you know?
Yeah.
Well those pass that you're talking
about,
those paths that are carved in that we.
We sort of normalize all the experiences
that we have so they look totally,
totally sane.
If you just straight off those paths and
jump into that Lake and freeze your Dick
off and get out and you just do.
Why did I do that?
What are you.
You broke your little Jane,
the little chain of programming that's
going on in your brain.
You did something completely unusual and
sometimes just little things like that
little deviations off of that path will
take you into a completely different
place.
Are you still doing that kind of thing
in your life now?
Yeah,
sure.
That all the time with wherever it's the
cryo chambers or the isolation tanks or
the experiences with WESCO and ask it,
but I've done a lot of dmt with the more
potent,
shorter lasting form.
Obviously I've read accounts on it.
I've never done it.
I'm in recovery,
so allegedly things can be rearranged if
you're in recovery.
The problem with recovery is,
you know,
uh,
if you want to maintain complete and
total sobriety,
the only way to allegedly have that
experience,
and apparently it is possible is through
Kundalini and.
But according to people I know that have
done both,
they've done dmt and they've also done
Kundalini.
It's virtually the same thing.
I'm like,
God can be reaching.
Yeah.
You just have to be completely dedicated
to the Kundalini practice.
You know,
you have to go to a very specific state
that's achievable once you have some
mastery.
Over the meditation and the Yoga
Principles,
I've done a fair bit of that.
Kundalini Yoga,
Bang into it.
In fact,
this toe on my forefinger here is an
illustration by Carl Young of the
Kundalini serpent.
The energy to come rises up.
Your animal energy can become the
coronated serp and bloodier getting that
toe down and I woke up in the middle of
the night,
severely regretting it.
Oh my thing go.
Why did I do that?
Mostly because Mark Mahoney,
the La tattooist that became sort of
somewhat besotted with him because he
would kind of like some sort of living
skeleton Elvis guy.
He mean so,
so sort of charming and enchanting.
I kept getting myself just silica him
out.
He appeared briefly in that film,
black mass,
that Johnny Depp Film.
I don't know if you saw it.
I didn't see the soldier.
That movie.
Yeah,
he's.
He has a cameo.
In the beginning of that you sort of got
blue ringtail was hey,
just sort of a fascinating guy and a
literal,
you know,
art is the proper tattoo artist.
People you know,
he's fast at these diode,
like gangster crime overlords
presidents.
Everybody's done sort of like a lot of
people,
but he's got a very easy way and it's
sort of a gentle kindness.
He told me this story once.
God,
I wonder if you'd mind me repeating this
in the media world when it used to be an
intravenous junkie.
He was in New York City and then you'd
like wandering along on the way to a
party and he saw a homeless fellow doing
paint,
Indonesia sort of for me and I'll get
those paintings and he bought these
paintings off this homeless guy and then
he went onto this part and then he went
and shot up in the bathroom and then he
heard a flurry of excitement at this
New York party because Andy Warhol,
Andy Warhol was arriving at the Party
and Warhol came upstairs and he said he
could hear like the acolytes around war,
how and he said he had.
He just banged up and he's getting a hit
and his eyes are rolling and he's
feeling fantastic and here's warhol
outside the room.
And Mark Mahoney had left some of his
paintings out there along with the works
of that homeless guy.
And he goes,
Whoa,
whoa.
Oh my God,
that's amazing.
Like looking at this stuff.
And he goes,
wow,
look at me.
I'm the coolest guy in the world is Mark
Mahoney.
I'm laying here banging up,
smack in a bathroom wall,
house out there,
dig in my work,
and of course when he went out it was
the homeless guy.
Stuff into.
Yeah,
he's a man with an anecdote or two.
I love that guy.
Your coffee's good,
mate.
I'm passing my tits.
Don't know what I'm saying.
So amazingly powerful for you.
This is it because I'm drug free for 13
years,
Joe and.
Oh,
so as I was saying Kundalini,
I've done a lot.
I couldn't and ever take you to a crazy
psychedelic state as I did when I was
using drugs.
I did psychedelics and it's.
I've never had that kind of like,
oh my God,
because I loved drugs.
But you never had a breakthrough moment
on psychedelics.
Yeah,
I had that realization.
What are considered to be myself was a
construction and it wasn't real,
but like my memories and my perception
and my desires are just a conglomeration
of biochemical impulses that Pew,
that I'm merely a conduit of pure
consciousness.
Then that's too heavy to deal with when
you're bloody 16.
All my mates were just doing it at
school and like,
you know,
carrying on like me,
I need to do psychedelics at the
hospital where a person monitoring my
heart going to be all right.
I can't do it under normal conditions.
So.
How old were you?
You weren't clean the 27.
So from 27 or nothing.
Just coughing.
I'm 41.
Yeah,
coffee.
Of course.
I was a sort of a,
you know,
pretty committed sex addict for a
decade.
You might want to dip your feet back in
the pond.
So you say this job,
this is
the problem is with me is I don't know
what your experience.
I know where your addictive tendencies
come out.
Well,
I have them for sure,
but uh,
where do they come out?
Um,
games or get addicted really badly to
games,
video games,
archery.
I'm addicted very badly to shooting bows
and arrows and he used to be cool.
Yeah.
Shoot.
Yeah,
I'm pretty good at it.
Robin Hood Style.
Well,
I don't use a recurve bow or use a
compound bow,
like a very complicated high powered
apparatus.
Shoots very accurately out to 70,
80,
90 yards,
but uh,
I practice it all the time.
Yeah,
it's fascinating.
It's a very.
It's a meditation.
Yeah.
Because there's something about when you
require so much concentration when
you're pulling a pullback and anchoring
and relaxing and centering the bow and
making sure everything's level and
relaxed and there's no excess movement
whatsoever.
As you release the Arrow.
It's all this very,
very difficult little dance of the
synapses that you're doing.
And in that dance,
there's no room for any extraneous
thought.
You think about your bills,
your bullshit,
your life death.
You don't think about anything but no
movement.
Release that Arrow.
Absolutely properly watched it sink into
the Bullseye and when you do it,
it's incredibly satisfying.
It must be made.
Is there some visualization involved in
that?
Yeah,
you definitely.
And a lot of people who will actually
get better from not even practicing.
They get better from visualizing.
More than practicing.
Yeah.
That they just,
they just go over the actual physical
mechanics of the shot,
visualize it locking in,
but it's a big thing with competitive
target archers,
the visualization aspect.
They go to hypnotists and they really
work on like a very specific pattern
that they visualize,
like a very specific pattern of drawing
the bow back,
finding your anchor point,
perfect release Arrow flying perfectly,
and in doing that they sort of
conditioned their mind and their body to
make that perfect shot over and over and
over again,
but it's so difficult to do that.
Even the best people fuck up the best
ones in the world and the Olympic
archery,
they'll occasionally,
you know,
get out of the line and get a nine or an
eight and they just,
they don't know why they'd been doing it
seven hours a day for fucking 20 years.
It doesn't matter.
It's so difficult that it net you.
There's no mastery.
You never totally master it.
There's variable.
You've got to be addicted.
If you go into a hypnotist and try to
hit bullseye,
man,
well imagine if that was your light in
it.
Imagine if that was how you made a
living,
how much you make,
and to be a narrative.
It's a good question.
I mean,
I know there's the Olympics,
right,
and so you can get sponsors from both
companies like [inaudible] and companies
that sell arrows and things along those
lines,
and it's.
It's a,
it's a practice that a lot of people
engage in,
so I would imagine it's probably more
money than you think there is.
Okay.
But yeah,
I just haven't seen it.
Even at the fairs are towards your
drawers for.
Here's the tricky thing is this doesn't.
It's not like,
like if you're.
If you're a professional boxer,
you have a very specific set of skills.
Right?
Right.
You know how to box floyd mayweather is
pretty.
God Damn sure he knows exactly what the
fuck he's doing,
but this isn't like boxing,
like anybody.
You can teach anybody to do this,
right?
It doesn't take any ridiculously
coordinated athletic movements,
some unusual genetic,
some fast twitch muscle fibers.
Now you just pull the bow back and you
release the Arrow.
So to make a living doing that,
to decide that I'm going to do something
that I could teach anybody to do in a
day.
I can take any regular person and work
on their footwork,
their stance rather and their
positioning and teach them how to shoot
an hour.
Yeah.
Breathing out of concentrate and relax.
You can get them shooting fairly
proficiently inside of four or five
hours.
Now imagine taking that to a level where
you're going to travel the world and
compete and just shoot at Bulls eyes for
your kids food.
That's what I'm saying.
It's a bunch of other people that are no
different than you.
There's.
I know a lot of those guys.
I know quite a few of those guys who
introduced me.
I will introduce you for sure.
Love to meet a professional guy that
I'll introduce you to.
The Guy who trained me,
John Dudley.
Next time he's in La and you're in La,
we'll make it happen.
He's a
good dude.
I want to learn about that madness.
Well,
Zealand motivation.
Jimbo to unravel this man.
Oh no person who's devoted their life to
hitting the bullseye
that led him to this point of mastery.
Don't make you feel insecure about the
hypnosis session.
Do you do yoga at all?
Ma'Am?
Do like regular yoga or Kundalini,
how often you do it?
I try and do yoga two or three,
like my exercise regimen change.
Not entirely unrelated to listening to
your podcast.
I like now do kickboxing once a week.
I do Jujitsu once a week and honestly
it's influenced me.
My Mate Nick got me into your podcast
and a lot of people that I hang out with
like,
you know,
sort of in there as you obviously know,
but even in the UK,
in the mixed martial art world,
this is a very central cultural artifact
and how it intersects with thinking
outside the box and a new vision of what
it is to be a man and living outside of
sort of state ideals and air
conditioning.
You know?
And that's very,
very,
I'm,
that's what I'm fascinated about is
these new,
like new ways of being a man like ha,
having tend to nurse awareness awakeness
but not being afraid or indeed ashamed
of the aspects of masculinity that have
somehow become cleverly maligned over
the last few generations.
So like may I say like a shout out to
the northwest and Paul busby because
they're the people side terminal people
that I do like.
That's a shout out to them.
I felt I was ridiculous there for
English and it was a hate crime.
You saw that.
I was giving them a shout out.
Oh right.
No,
that's actually.
That's another great one.
And there's no.
There's no doubt that the English accent
is the greatest accent.
That's why I use it for all noble
movies.
Any time there's a god or any sign
there,
you're speaking in a foreign language
that we've translated to English.
They have an English accent or anything.
Thrones,
gladiator,
everybody squats revolutions after all
of your economic success and Global
Dominion when it comes to an authority
figure used to come down from on the
heart,
you still can't have God.
God is actually still have a sort of
sense of realness,
game of thrones,
reverence for the regal,
but they're all.
They all speak some strange language
during some place with dragons.
It's all artificial,
right?
But yet they all speak with an English
accent.
No reason why they should not be from
Detroit.
Yeah.
Why?
Why don't they speak,
hey,
you fucking guys were coming over here
trying to fuck our broad
fucking balls and it's good.
Well,
it's fucking dragons in Shane.
Black in your dragons ask you to leave
the court because you've really loved
the tone some lot.
So it's like the opposite of going off
the course.
It's going so deep into the chorus that
everyone's wearing powdered wigs and
they're all aligning with some ancient
scrolls that they've pulled out of a jar
and a fucking cave and come somewhere
and it
has been decreed.
And you say everything's going to be
proper.
Yeah,
he's getting deep.
That's what I count on you guys for you
English properly and rely on us from now
the time in memorial because he sort of
burping during that stuff.
Yeah.
So that like I go do Jujitsu once a week
at a level that you know,
I mean I don't even know if it would
qualify for,
for the term Jujitsu at that level.
Up and practicing at the moment.
I've doing kickboxing where I had to go
to what is called a leisure center to
those words exist in nature center,
like a gym,
a community,
one to do my,
like white boy can see why MCA lined up
with like 10 year olds do in life to get
my white belt just to get on the ladder.
I do know,
I mean I've done that quite recently and
as well as that I do do yoga,
so I'm so I'm using this time.
I've stepped out of the madness of Los
Angeles.
The Madness of media that like,
you know,
the intensity of it,
during the time of what was like in
another thing that you talks about is
the shadow self.
All the.
I am not.
I also am.
If you think of that as I suppose a
simpler way of saying that is I've lived
this life that's been very focused on
comedy and the pursuit of individual
success.
Think what are all the things I've not
done as a result of that?
Like when I was a king and he's shy and
too ashamed to get into sort of like
sport type things,
you know,
and embarrassed and all that kind of
thing,
so you have to start to do kickboxing or
Jujitsu and even football or soccer as
you call it here,
you know,
like to do all of those things now to
start to learn about them as an adult
man,
it's a beautiful
thing when you take chances and do
things with other people that are take
chances and chances and doing new things
because you realize that it's really.
A lot of it is about the sort of
acceptance and the embracing of
vulnerability.
When you learn a new thing,
it's very important to learn new things
that it is that you.
Because I hear you say that and I know
what that means,
but the you actually could like I got so
much prejudice is about you as a sort of
a black belt.
Martial law is then as someone who is
embedded in the MMA mma world,
you are a person who is happy and
accepting of vulnerability.
Where in your life do you feel that you
are in embracing that vulnerability in
every.
Every time you try something new?
I enjoy.
I'm like in the archery thing,
I've only been doing it for four years,
but one of the things that I really
loved about is how fucking terrible I
was when I first started and it was like
there's,
there's something to this that I have to
figure out.
Yoga is a big one.
I've been really serious into yoga like
where I go several times a week at least
once a week for about a year and a
couple months,
a year and like two months or something
like that.
And one of the things that I really
enjoy about it is that I'm not very good
and I still get nervous before class.
Fuck man.
Yeah,
it's weird.
There's something.
It's one of those weird places,
like a yoga class is one of those weird
places where there's almost a sacredness
to it.
Like you,
you go in there and no one can leave
until the class is over.
Like they tell you,
they lock the front door and no one
comes in to visit the studio.
Everything's locked in.
No one watches.
You go in there and we don't talk.
No one talks.
You don't talk for 90 and you go through
this series of poses that are incredibly
difficult.
You're sweating like pounds and pounds
of water up.
I mean I'll,
I'll weigh myself before and after.
I'll be down like four or five pounds
just from one class and it's very
difficult,
but it makes me nervous,
you know?
I do get nervous before I do it because
it has this.
I think it's difficult to do.
I think I don't necessarily physically
enjoy it while it's happening,
but I enjoy the effects after it's over.
But I think it definitely imparts a
feeling of vulnerability.
Hmm.
Because I always issue that if you are
really good at this is perhaps you know,
because of where I come from,
I always assumed that if you are date
good at some sort of fight in thing,
that that is a highly transferable skill
like that.
And I don't mean in a practical way,
if you're good at kickboxing,
you will also be good at yoga.
I just mean if you're good at
kickboxing,
you don't give a shit that you're not
good at yoga.
My assumption is if you're good at yoga,
the yoga side,
you're not meant to say you're good at
Yoga.
But giovan could it
sort of like when I'm in the MMA gym,
start guiding like,
well,
you may be strangling me now,
my man,
but wait till we get to down with dog.
No,
I sort of feel that.
All right.
Live humility into Jujitsu situation for
a beginner is an absolute humility.
He recognized,
you know,
because I'm dealing with people that are
good and like,
you know,
they have to do it like they're doing it
for a little kid,
you know,
like,
and I'm very aware that they're doing
that
well.
I think that if you get really good at
martial arts,
the only way to get really good is to be
completely objective about where you
are.
And if you're completely objective about
where you are and learning and trying to
improve upon your skills,
you apply that same feeling towards
everything else.
So the feeling that you get when you
totally vulnerable in martial arts,
you apply that same feeling when you're
learning yoga because that's the only
way to get really good at it.
The only way to really do it to 100
percent do it.
It's not to sit here and go,
this doesn't mean shit because I could
choke on it,
but in this going to help you,
it's not going to help you at all.
Matter of fact,
it'll hurt you,
and it'll focus more on your own ego
instead of the ego dissolving.
Beneficial properties of the poses.
Oh,
drew and the ambience in the yoga
studio.
I would say that out loud doesn't mean
shit.
I could choke everyone in this room.
Well know I could fuck you up.
So settle down.
Don't get crazy about you're stretching.
I don't know if you've read the
scriptures,
but there is no guidance.
Quite a little foreign.
And it's usually a metaphor.
That was the thing that Mckenna always
talk about that that's really what a lot
of the ancient yogis were about.
They were about smoking chillums of Hash
and then doing all these poses and if
you've ever done yoga while intoxicated
on edible,
the edible variety in particular
marijuana.
It's a beautiful thing.
I haven't because I only started yoga
because I'd stopped in a hash and all
other drugs.
You know like when the thing is with me
mate is when I was taking drugs,
that was what I was doing.
There wasn't room for.
Now I might pop to yoga.
You were fucking pro.
I was a full time dedicated pro 100
percent.
That's it.
Everyday,
you know,
can't do.
It was the amount.
What was the big drug was the problem.
I progressed through an escalation of
drug use.
That could be on any republican leaflet
case,
stone smoke pot or you will become a
heroin addict.
That's literally what I did.
Like I started with recreational drugs
was unable to properly.
The reason is this because it's not the
fault of the drugs themselves.
There's a component within me that he's
looking to find a solution that doesn't
happen.
You see when you have that perspective
on guy and in a place and being willing
to go in there and be vulnerable.
That kind of thing.
For me,
that makes me very sort of what are
called hot,
you know,
like scared like that or fuck fuck
tiffany drugs were always a thing that I
trusted to make me feel a little bit
better light and so when I was smoking
weed,
it's like,
all right,
there's that thing I've found that makes
me feel relaxed when coke and heroin and
crack.
It was the same reason.
It was an attempt to nullify,
medicate and contend with an innocent of
disconnectedness and discontentment,
which I think is a thing that comes up a
lot on your show in other guys because I
think that's in some way or another,
we're all looking for the sense of
connection,
the sense of completion.
I think in fact,
the thing that led me to be a drug
addict or a sex addict gambler,
wherever kind of addict you are,
I think the thing that's driving it is
this need for connection.
The sense that if this life,
because it don't fucking seem right to
me now this system like give me the real
deal.
What's the real thing you're not telling
me?
And that's why I'm fascinated by people.
Like terrence Mckenna says,
like if you.
You know what he dunks down the
pedestrian levels of consciousness.
There's this deep,
deep shit down there.
There's fascinating stuff.
There's machine elves,
there's corridors of kaleidoscopic
wonder to explore.
There's union,
there's God.
You know,
for garlic,
you maybe the best art.
That might be the best argument for
trying to do with the Kundalini way
because you have to earn it,
right?
I knew it'd be harder for me.
I've got,
I've got to do it by sort of stretching
and sort of aggressive breathing.
Instead of hitting that dmt shit
into my leathery old lungs.
Just take three.
You just take three and then you sit
back and tell me what you see at the
end.
In about 15 minutes.
You can't.
You can't,
can't be described beyond language to
describe it.
It's just my stubby fucking stupid ape
fingers trying to draw God with a crayon
on a patch of dirt.
It's not even a proper canvas problem of
all religions can.
It's just a question.
If you do see what you were actually
looking for,
what do you think is curious once you
there and you discover what,
what do you come back and aren't we just
backed all of this
even?
No,
you're right in waiting,
but because I have had moments in both
sobriety recovery,
Andy in active addiction where I've
gone,
Oh God,
I feel truly connected now.
I've had a lot of those moments in what
I would call unhealthy high.
It's like,
you know,
sort of sexual kind of,
Oh my God,
this is so amazing.
I want to live in this moment forever.
Or moments on drugs where I felt sort of
pure bliss,
but nowadays I tend to find it through
bloody altruism and kindness and
service.
Like sometimes when I think I'm being
truly useful,
I feel this sense of connection,
but you are right,
it is not sustainable.
There is no Viagra for enlightenment.
You can't sort of stay hard.
You know what I mean?
You sort of,
you feel like,
oh,
that's it.
I understand it right from this moment
for virome,
enlightened,
I'm.
That's it.
I'm never going to be anybody's bitch
again.
I'm never going to do anything straight
for the money.
I'm never going to care what other
people think about me ever again.
It's actually,
it's behind me,
but then someone will say something or
someone will do something enough back
here again,
I think it's very hard to capture the
divine.
You know?
I think you'd get like I've had in my
life moments of it.
I think when I do the yoga,
I practice yoga on my own practice,
yoga this morning and positions where
you go upside down and stuff and I think
you would if he was just determined to
describe things in a material and
secular way,
you'd say,
well,
you would just dizzy,
you know,
but what I feel is I go upside down and
when I come up straight again,
I feel my own individual consciousness.
My sense of myself.
I feel it sort of disappeared.
Like I can't remember who I am for a
moment.
It all goes away and then I feel this
secondary awareness in the back of my
mind.
Like I sort of a grid and awareness.
There's a nice sort of thing.
Hold on a minute,
I'm not me.
There's something else inside of me and
the thing that in a might big sort of ax
to grind.
When I was doing that,
that Internet series the truth for a
while.
That got me into all sorts of
interesting scrapes and challenges over
the last sort of 18 months,
two years.
It was the idea of someone inside our
own consciousness is not free.
We are not free within our own
consciousness.
We have been conditioned to the point
that we don't know that we're
conditioned anymore and I think that
that sort of,
you know,
that's you.
You notice it in lightening rod moments
when there is sort of like an election
and you think,
oh my God,
people really in his fucking shit what
is going on my rage
cage.
Perfect riff to at that moment.
Thank you very much this way.
Yeah.
Is that rage against the machine?
Is that person smashing?
Smashing pumpkin.
I don't limit.
Can I ask you,
since [inaudible] you found your outlet.
You said you're putting you finding just
good.
Something good?
Yeah.
Have you.
I'm just a question since you've been
putting it out there and have you
noticed this more and more is coming
back or it's like,
Eh,
I'm noticing it more always was there.
I just chose go the way to know.
These are just questions.
Well my right eye.
It still like if you read any bloody,
when you read this stuff in religious
books like saying the Bible is going to
become good and get to the point where
even being good,
you're not even doing it for that reason
anymore.
You've become detached from outcomes.
You know the.
In Buddhist terms,
you know like that you're,
you're no longer about fear and desire.
You no longer trying to just fulfill
yourself.
Right?
I'm not bloody there yet.
You know me,
even if I do something good like go a
homeless shelter and help out for the
day and all that sort of thing,
a little bit of the back of my mind is
going to helping out at this homeless
shelter
and if someone went by and saw me
helping at the homeless shelter,
been really pleased.
Why is no one seeing me helping these
fucking ownership.
So I'm still a little bit looking for
rewards now that that's very hard.
But this is the thing is as well about
being a comedian is you can't get to
fucking sincere and earnest.
Do you stop being bloody funny.
You know what I mean?
But then you find that that when you
stuff that you really passionate about
and you really believe in because
comedy,
I think he's constantly ripping down
the,
you know,
you sort of set up a premise and then
you rip it down again.
I think comedy is the energy of
constantly going.
None of this is really.
No,
this is all bullshit.
It's all fucking bullshit.
So when you're sincere,
you please hold on,
hold on.
Stop it.
No,
this is serious.
That's more kids will care about them.
Once you do that,
be able to differentiate between your
forms of expression,
like your art form,
like a piece that you're creating and
you yourself as a person.
And sometimes I used to think when I was
younger,
man,
I can't be fucking around with
meditation or enlightenment because it's
going to ruin me.
All my favorite comedians were junkies
and crazy people like in and prior and
Hicks and crazy people and junkies.
You can't get enlightened.
You gotta you gotta just gotTa fucking
be a wild man.
That's how you get comedy.
I'm not so convinced anymore.
And I think the creating of these memes
and,
and these,
these characters that you can mock and
make fun of inside your act is a piece
of art.
You're doing something just like a
painting doesn't make you a madman.
You could paint a Frazetta,
Conan the barbarian painting.
It doesn't make you a mass murderer.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like you're creating a piece of art
and sometimes the more points of view
that you've considered,
the more it enhances that work of art.
You raise a good point in that because
in certain sectors of the art world that
has always been accepted that you know,
erroneous Bosch triptych of hell don't
mean,
oh man,
this guy's fucking crazy.
You know,
they may have been,
I don't know or you know,
but like when in hip hop,
you know,
like people talk about,
popping caps and whatnot.
It's taken a lot more literally and it.
And as a comedic persona like that,
he's gonna comedians get a lot,
but it British comedian as well.
There's a few sort of like comedians,
myself,
a Scottish comedian called Frankie Boyle
like that when people are very shocking,
like you know,
like,
like you can,
I can tell sometimes that comics are
saying things to detonate territory's of
consciousness.
Fuck you knew because it might get
lucky.
Wakes you up.
Bill Hicks did that a lot.
I think he would say things.
You go whoa,
steady and then these smacked you in the
mouth and then he's like,
he gently tells you that it's just the
ride or wherever it is,
you know,
like now that you've got you where wants
you.
But people like I think we live in a
culture now that's very prohibitive
about where we go with those kind of
idea.
So people are very quick.
I've myself been on the receiving end of
a lot of like what I want to say
judgment and I'm not fucking joking but
don't.
That's also because we live in this new
media world of social interaction,
this new social media world where
anybody can chime in at any point in
time and it's the first time ever that
that's happened.
Yeah,
you might be right,
but a friend of mine in England made a
documentary about what has happened to
the idea of the great man,
you know,
like in American literature,
like,
you know,
Saul Bellow Philip Roth or like,
Mohammed Ali,
uh,
rest in peace like that.
Nowadays,
people don't rise to that position
anymore because there's thousands of
Lilliputians pulling them down as soon
as there is above the parapet and no
one's allowed to.
Yeah,
yeah.
People will be,
oh,
well Martin Luther King had affairs on
Malcolm x.
He was inside.
He done this,
that,
and the other.
You know,
like,
it's like the,
the.
Yeah,
I,
there were so many good things that have
come from social media.
So many good things,
you know,
the possibility of communication,
that connection and instantaneous,
all those things.
This is wonderful,
but it does all,
all things in the end become an
expression of the dominant
consciousness,
you know,
and if people are doubtful,
cynical,
president mystic in that,
the Palette that she ends up on the
canvas,
it also might be a case of,
you know,
everybody's always worried about wealth
inequality in this world.
There's also a possibility of
consciousness,
inequality and that these people that
have grown up with shitty parents and
shitty neighborhoods,
they feel left out by even your ability
to seek peace and altruism.
Like,
who are you this guy?
Why are you so lucky?
You're financially fortunate.
You have beautiful genes.
You're handsome,
you have a wonderful magazine,
fucking magazine shop.
I go get your face.
I mean I love you dude,
but come on,
Bang and started off this motherfucker.
And so why is he so happy?
Why is he allowed to have this happiness
come to him so easily?
So there's anger at that.
The same kind of anger that you would
get at the elite upper class,
like the billionaires in the one
percenters of the world.
People will also look at a person like
you and like there's a consciousness
inequality,
there's a,
there's also a starting point.
Inequality,
you know,
I'm sure you,
like you were saying you were insecure
when you're young and it was difficult
than I certainly was and Jim and I knew
each other when we're young and insecure
and starting out as comics.
We've been friends forever,
but that,
that sort of this,
this experience where you are,
you now and people look at that and
they're upset that,
well,
why is this guy have so much?
Why is this guy in this place where you
can so conveniently search for truth
where I have to pay my fucking bills,
student loans,
and I'm in a Shitty neighborhood and my
kids are sick and my wife account,
you know,
this is this.
And then they get on twitter and the
like,
fuck you,
you fucking cunt.
I hope your ponytail chokes you and your
right.
Well,
it never will because I'll put it into a
button.
I can actually understand that level of
discontentment because to be honest,
I,
you know,
I'm subject to jealousy and envy myself.
I spot it when it comes up,
when I sort of feel myself go,
oh,
why is that not me?
I should be having that.
But now I try to.
I try not to justify feeling shit.
Know as soon as I start feeling bad,
I don't think,
well this is why I feel bad and I'd like
to stay feeling bad if I try and go,
hold on a minute that I,
if I,
if you believe that you know,
the external world is an illusion that
it's temporary,
it's transient and real is your deep
connection to your inner self and you
can express that myriad ways and we're
here to after this experience as an
animal and I'm fascinated by the
numerous ways that you are into doing it
and it's something that I really want to
learn more about,
you know,
loads of the stuff that goes on on your
show,
but like,
yeah,
I can,
I can well appreciate people sort of
seeing a.
yeah.
Particularly as the way it's presented,
seen me on the like on television
thinking,
fuck that guy,
fuck that guy because they don't
automatically know where I came from or
what I had to do to get here,
or the fact that I get here and take.
Hold on a minute.
This isn't why full.
It will be almost as soon as I got those
things.
I was like,
this isn't real.
If you can't make yourself,
you know,
like the,
I don't want to be poor again.
I'll be straight about that because I
hate it.
It is pretty frightening,
but like it's.
You cannot resolve those inner issues.
I now know that empirically for a fact.
I'm really lucky and that's why I'm so
fascinated by the addiction model and
that's why I'm reluctant to smash my
mind's piece of DMT though.
It does sound fun.
I would really,
really love to do it on pier pussy.
I'll do it
for you.
Say I'm in
is because I know I've tried fame,
I've tried money,
I tried drugs,
I tried sex.
I tried all of those things to make
myself feel better and oddly none of
them have worked.
None of them have worked.
I'm not.
Oh,
poor me.
Poor me.
What is fucking refugee crisis?
You just about your experience.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I would like what I am now thinking
Joe is what is the Mo they say that,
you know,
happiness is where,
what the world needs meets what you have
to offer,
where we can meet,
well needs,
meet what you have to offer,
and I think God is there a way that I
can communicate some of the things that
I have learned about connecting,
about letting go of my floors,
taking responsibility for the problems
that I am creating,
you know,
like is there anything about that that I
can convey kind of conveyed hopefully as
we were in a comedic and accessible way
and that sort of like where my focus is
beginning to fall now I'm assuming
that's what you're already doing.
I'm attempting.
I mean everybody.
I think everybody is trying to better
themselves as attempting some form of
that,
but it's also what you're dealing with
when you're talking about the criticism
of you.
They're trying to define you based on
one interview or one,
one article or one thing that you said
in response to one piece of current
events,
so it's real quote mining a lot of times
in a lot of ways.
Looking to have a more concentrated form
of that,
that jealous expression we were talking
about like fine,
like it's gotta be something about this
guy I don't like.
That's it.
I don't like how he went on Fox News and
mocked America.
Hey,
you mocking the journalism.
Yeah.
You think you're better than these
people that are here and telling the
truth.
Well,
I think the way that works for me is
that that is a thing that is called
confirmation bias,
isn't it?
You've already feeling something inside
yourself and then you'll sort of
unconsciously you're scanning data to
get confirmation of like.
So if I feel insecure because you're
super good at MMA and have black bolts
in Jujitsu,
I like,
instead of dealing with my own feeling
of fuck,
if this becomes a fire,
I'm not going to have to deal with it.
I would rather go,
wow,
this guy's like,
I'll find something to complete the had
advantages that I didn't have if I had
this I would've been like in.
But,
but really the feeling is in me,
and this is what might personal
experience of actually getting clean
from drugs has taught me,
is that,
you know,
what other people think about me is none
of my business and it's something that's
happening in their own consciousness and
they're always looking for some
coordinates upon which to project those
feelings.
And I know that because I fucking knew
it when I,
if I start getting jealous about,
you know,
super awesome,
super successful guy or someone who's
super good at fighting or whatever,
that's I'm dealing with something inside
myself.
So now I try not to bring that shit to
the world and trying to go.
Right?
Russell,
you bet.
Deal with this feeling of inadequacy or
this feeling of jealousy or this feeling
of insecurity because what was just
going to ruin your experience of being
human instead of going,
no,
the problem is this guy or that guy or
this person having a successful podcast.
I tried to go,
none of Russell connect with yourself,
you know,
I'm trying not to blame the outside
world for my shit and yeah,
these are really complicated thoughts
that we have and in many ways we're
almost a victim of this constant need to
evolve like the body and the brain is
set up to constantly be comparing
ourselves to others and to feed off of
each other,
whether it's through jealousy or
inspiration to try to achieve higher and
higher levels of competency at anything,
to develop more social credibility,
to develop more clout in the community,
to,
to feel better about your own existence.
It's almost like what we're dealing with
is some sort of a programming that is
constantly set up to innovate and to
continue to get better and better at
everything.
So yeah,
if I see you in some movie,
am I.
where Am I?
How come I'm not in these fucking
movies?
I don't even get these auditions.
I need a farmland manager.
These ideas,
they.
They motivate movement,
they motivate momentum and yes you could
use them or not using,
but we don't.
We don't know how to handle them and no
one's telling us in.
Our parents didn't tell us and their
parents didn't tell them shit.
Back to the slavery.
We're all just tribal and at the end of
the day,
what you supposed to do is help others.
There's no better feeling in the world
then encouraging another human to live
right and they live right.
Those are moments you remember live good
judge,
and your Dick Sucked and the lyrics
while you're pouring champagne on both
of you.
Oh No,
that is relaxing
background
check.
That's quicker.
If you can't get a learjet
debate,
I am going to take that out of your
mouth.
You,
you mean a good point because what
you're doing right there is how
biological imperatives,
wherever that force was,
that made us divide from one cell to two
cells to 10 sales,
to the frog,
to Malmo,
to cities to woolies and wonders.
That falls,
as you say,
still in us now,
these,
these imperatives to grow,
that's the,
you know that as a you sign an agent,
but as if you're living in a tribal
society,
it's a necessary function,
but what's happened to our species?
Because you know that father,
that cliche you are what you eat.
You know what it means.
If you eat shit food,
you'll be shit and I hundred percent
agree with that,
but on a,
on a different,
in a different way.
You are what you eat.
If you look at what we eat now,
we mono cultural foods.
You know like we're in a suedes endless
fields of wheat across again.
Got It.
Drove what state would that have been?
Drove fruit,
like there's one of your crazy Iowa,
Nebraska,
nothing,
but it was like the whole country was
made of it.
Just know what else is there.
Go on Jesus.
Oh,
I love that guy.
Now he's guilty,
but do you understand what he was
saying?
The May.
The main thing that I think he was
saying was,
don't be gay.
That's what I like,
so
just be cool.
He said
what?
He said,
yeah,
a lot of people have missed the point,
but this big cool thing,
it's done again.
It's focused down on not big guy,
and then of course the way that the meat
is consumed,
endless apa towards and slaughter houses
have condensed animals not consumed as
they would be tribally picked off here
and there even once a week.
I'm a vegetarian myself,
but you know,
so we have fields full of wheat.
Abbotts was full of meat and we
ourselves are similarly what we eat.
We have become cells of energy trapped
in cities.
Not Free to be tribal beings anymore.
We've become so disconnected from what
it's supposed to be to be this primate
that now these biological imperative,
the desire to procreate,
the desire to have status,
that the,
the desire to even get high,
all these things have become permutate
it because they're no longer anchored in
the reality for which we were design.
I imagine your position where you are in
a completely unique position,
even in the Western world,
you become a media superstar.
You become a movie star.
He becomes someone when you show up,
people have cameras and you walk and
they take photos of you.
You get out of a car and everyone
cheers.
It becomes this really unusual event
when you just arrived somewhere.
So it sets you up for an incredibly high
dose of this sort of toxic celebrity
feeling that you have to sort of
navigate and you have to navigate it
based on the other people that have
mostly unsuccessfully navigated it
before you start and think about how
many fucking movie stars wind up in a
pool their own or you know,
covered in whatever the fuck they're
doing it.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a large number of famous people
wind up fucking it all up,
but they can't handle it anymore.
They go,
he's ledger or a million different ways,
you know,
pills are just fucking implosion or
whatever the fuck it is.
Would you like to feed my giraffe?
This is the podcast for you.
Start losing your mind
in the van.
For anyone that's listening to this
podcast,
just because I'm on it and I can't
imagine there's very many of you.
There's a reference there to a giraffe
that even I'm struggling.
It's.
I just think that your unique
perspective and it's a very unique
perspective because not a lot of people
get to become movie stars,
is it's something that the average
person,
they are trying to put it into
perspective where they can grasp the
amount of pressure and the weird way
that you have to interface with the
world where people worship you and
everywhere you go people love you and
you don't even know them.
That's a very strange thing.
This is the thing.
We have to think of problems.
I think in terms of their essence,
not of their scale,
you see like because if you like how I
stopped myself,
like,
you know,
when I was more immersed in Hollywood
and fame and stuff,
I like,
it isn't like you walk in a room and
like when I was single and a lots of
attention from women,
obviously that that's a short circuit
that because you do tend to fulfill that
one.
You said,
Oh my God,
I'm able to have sex with.
Awesome.
Let's dig sense.
All of a sudden they want,
you know,
how did that happen?
That was amazing.
It was like,
it was hurting of the natural process.
Matrix is broken.
Oh my God.
I'm fucking.
Yeah,
I lost my wonder why you're an addict.
It's normal,
but every look it's called pussy is
awesome.
That is a difficult problem.
To overwhelmed.
It's impossible.
It's impossible to avoid the pool.
I mean,
you talking about the gravity of
Jupiter,
it's sucks and asteroids.
I mean,
that's what it is.
It's just too goddamn strong.
The compulsion to breed and the
compulsion to be special so that you can
breed more than anyone else and you can
have the choice.
That's what your DNA calls,
but can we overcome our nature?
You have,
you have.
You have a
podcast I've ever been in my life.
What you're doing,
you've decided to step away from all the
bullshit,
move away from Hollywood and sort of
take a break while you can financially
and you can with your position in life
and just relax and get a look at this
because it don't look at it from afar.
Maybe the ego thing of like people
giving you those attention.
Why used to.
Oh,
like quite quickly after.
Like I used to get a lot of fame
attention.
I would think if someone else more
famous than me came in,
then all these attention would go there.
So what is it really well is it really
is not it.
I can't feed on that and even if I don't
have that,
even if I don't literally have the
experience of being of basking in a
spotlight and then Justin timberlake
walking in and seeing the light
disappear from my face and being
punished once again into the shadows of
my youth.
Even if I don't have to actually have
that experience,
I know that when I get home,
I'm still just that none of it is real
that you can't.
There's no nutrition in it.
There's nothing we ended.
You can't get any.
It's not like,
oh,
this,
this amount of fame hasn't worked.
I'll try and get even more famous is
because the essence is the thing.
The essence is the thing is to try to
connect what I am doing or what you are
doing or what one is doing to something
that is connected that feels beautiful
to you,
that fills nutritional to you and that.
For me that is really,
really odd because it's very hard to
enjoy those pat on the back things.
Particularly if you know,
like if you felt inadequate and insecure
in Adelaide,
it's very hard to break off of that
track course and I'll feel lucky,
but it's not something that it's not
over for me.
If feel.
I feel lucky to be awakening from that
thing.
I feel lucky to be awakening for her,
but it's not over for me.
I still feel it.
You know?
I still feel if someone,
if another English committee,
if Ricky Gervais' came in,
now I'd have to go.
Right.
Okay.
Ricky,
JCC,
Sacha Baron Cohen.
Right now this is happening now.
I'm aware that in this moment I have a
cache of being the only English person
in the West was,
but it's not.
You know,
if those are the things I'm using a prop
up my identity,
I'm fucked.
But you being aware of those facts,
aware of the fact that you're constantly
struggling in this is what's going to
help you.
I mean,
it's not like you can avoid the,
the sound of the.
What are the harpies one of those things
and pull the sirens that call the boats
into the rocks.
Like it's,
it's,
it's compelling.
It's absolutely compelling,
but you understand what it is now so you
don't have to do it.
You don't have to gravitate towards it.
Like you know you can.
You know that if you just went and got a
bunch of hookers and some coke and hold
yourself up in a hotel room,
there'd be some moments.
It'd be pretty God damn good about that,
but they're also,
there'd be the repercussions,
the fact that you've slid back towards
addiction,
the problem,
so you avoid it.
You know the pool is always going to be
there,
especially when the girls have big tits
and little waist bigger ashes and put a
secret.
Yes.
It's a very difficult.
That's why.
That's why I live in the abstinence
model that's.
I tried to press those buttons because
that's stuff is,
you know,
you can't miss route the cage.
Don't wake that guy up.
Leave him alone like hulk in it.
Don't make me angry.
Learned Lot and whenever I agree,
just let me be a little hole.
Yeah,
just let me chill.
I mean look,
as we've gone over your navigating some
waters that very few people get to go
through and there's no books written
about it.
No one has gone through what you've done
and achieved some sort of a yogic state
of enlightenment where they've sort of
expressed it to everybody else and said,
this is,
this is the roadmap.
This is the path
I have to.
I have to just say,
just knowing some addicts to me,
what you're doing is more powerful than
when you were the ultimate ultimate
star.
Because I'm telling this guy sometimes.
I mean,
we all feel that way.
I'll get really far for a little bit.
I'll go,
you know,
I can't believe that guy.
I'm trying to do this,
and that guy,
he's,
I think he's 15 years now and he'll turn
to me.
Go,
Jim,
I've been to your house,
have so much more.
You have so much more in your life.
You don't want.
Trust me.
You don't want that.
It's a struggle,
but when he says that,
those statements are so powerful to make
as he can see that that vanity and
wanting to be.
That's why I said the draft,
because that defines my success.
You know,
success with I board the draft shipped
here.
I'm faithful.
That shit is worse than heroin.
It's worse than her.
I can't imagine his ladder was.
Is it was.
Was still is up here in a similar way
here.
That's a lot to live.
I don't know.
I tip my hat to you,
but you would go through a tornado,
but he's done it.
You've done in a similar way as well in
some his love,
his level,
but Jim was on Saturday night live is
one of the best comedians in the
country,
is one of the best standup comics in the
world.
Really fucking crushes.
He's so God damn funny,
but he decided we'd been friends
forever.
He decided a long time ago,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I'm going to live in New Jersey.
I'm going to do gigs and I'm not going
to worry about nothing.
I'm just going to have a good time and
perform and not worry about fame at all.
I'm just going to step the fuck away and
just work on my act.
Work on performing,
having a good time of trying to enjoy my
life and that's a very admirable thing
to what you've done is a very admirable
thing and a lot of ways I can.
But when you first walked in here,
you just kind of mentioned that and you
said,
um,
suburbanized.
I'm suburbanized you said that a couple
times and indicated domestic kid.
I'm sorry.
You said domesticated.
Don't have suburbs in England.
No,
you have the country and not that
domesticated pit fall.
To me it's more,
it's more you get more a gratitude out
of it and the end of your days,
those are the moment you can remember
those little moments whether it was
your,
your friend or whatever.
There's nothing wrong with that world
and you can always come back one
possibility.
That's the problem though.
I warned my wife.
Tell like,
listen,
kids got a couple of years kids around
in there and I tell them,
don't get fuck pregnant man up 20 years
from going ape shit and I will have that
right to go ape shit.
I watched my father,
World War Two vet go into 18 years old
and I watched them go,
I'm just going to go ape shit.
I don't give a shit about anything
anymore.
Um,
so what you're doing is to me that's I'm
cheering,
cheer you on.
Big Time.
And I know this is Corny,
but I saw you on a couple of interviews
soon as you were.
I mean you were,
you were all over the place and I could
see.
I can see you in that room trying to
find who you were while everyone else
was trying to throw out a completely
different character.
I,
maybe I'm crazy and I'm going right now,
but I,
I would see that.
I'm like,
oh,
well you had the awareness to say this
is all weird.
It feel weird.
It's the weirdest way.
Haired.
How could it not be weird?
You're a movie star.
It's creepy.
He's in a very unusual experience
because it's like you were saying about
going back to and sort of saying that,
right?
What I'm going to do is my job,
I'm going to do comedy and I do the
comedy to get the money to pay for the
food,
to feed my family,
to take care of my life and I love doing
it and I can bring joy to people.
They're like,
I,
if I'm honest about myself,
I always had the ingredients for
obsessive behavior.
I was because like the more I look at
it,
I was trying to resolve something.
I've thought if I get there,
then I'll be worth something.
I can get that thing and they know when
I got there thought,
hold on,
this isn't eight reeve and real.
It doesn't feel right to me.
It doesn't feel right and that's not
like,
you know,
there are people sort of I think very
high profile,
high level people that are making big
contributions.
Can you sweep away all of mainstream
culture?
Can you say the sole function of pop
culture is to keep people but wilderness
and distracted and intoxicated.
While the political elite in conjunction
with the corporate powers can saps the
energy of the great and powerful people
of this planet?
Yes.
You can,
but like I do think that that's a
conscious decision by the cultural elite
or is that a conscious decision by the
people to avoid reality itself and be
distracted by Goofy television?
It must've been.
It must be sort of both components must
be both,
but like you said,
implied or said even earlier,
we are still evolving.
Evolution is still happening.
It's not over easy and like so what I
feel like it's what I feel like is at
what information can we impart,
how can we,
you know,
this is extremely successful as I said
before,
cultural artifact.
You can just keep pumping alternative
ideas in people's head.
If people start to hear it again and
again,
you're being lied to about civilization.
It's been brought to older.
You're being lied to about the nature of
consciousness.
You're being lied to about your options.
You know,
like on a very simple level.
I've had got,
as you,
I'm sure I've gathered quite a lot of
therapy over the course of my life and
as a result of their substance misuse,
addictions,
and then just out of ongoing bloody
curiosity.
And I say,
the function of therapy is to increase
your choices in life because none of us
lives in reality.
Anyone who's bloodied and the empty,
we'll know we don't live in reality.
We live in a narrow,
tiny bandwidth of reality.
So if you just live in a model of
reality,
not reality itself,
then you should take responsibility for
remodeling your reality,
particularly the not bloody api in it.
You can change it,
you can change your consciousness.
And for me at the moment that means
quite mundane things.
It means that when I arrive here and my
suitcases don't arrive,
I'll have the choices of do I now become
account and make people's lives fucking
miserable?
Or do I just accept the cases are not
here.
This is,
this is the reality.
Or when I arrive at the airport and I
ain't got my green card,
but I really miss the flight like all,
all of these,
I just thought,
oh,
this is happening right now.
The only choice I have in that moment is
the choice of whether or not to stop
being a dick.
And,
and I tried not to now and in the past I
was like,
fuck you,
I'm excited.
It is fairly well.
It's so easy to just get absorbed in it.
My friend Tony Visa,
this once.
I know I've repeated this on the podcast
before,
but my friend Tony v C drive from,
you know Tony Vee,
stand up comedian.
I don't think.
Boston guy,
hilarious guy.
He used to drive from New York to Boston
all the time,
like almost every day.
He was constantly driving.
It's a pain in the ass like two and a
half hours of two and a half hours back,
whatever it is.
New York to Boston.
And what does it thrive?
No,
that's a good foreign like a pussy,
Schatz.
Michael,
you had a lot of PBA cars are saying
it's not that far for fucking hours.
What are you talking about?
I would say three at the most.
Anyway,
he drove,
he drove it all the time and,
and he was talking about what he did was
he just went and zen and he said,
this is what I'm doing now.
The way he dealt with it.
He's like,
now I'm driving like there's no,
there's no upset is known.
This is what I'm doing,
I'm doing this and if the cars are all
stopped and we're all going five miles
an hour,
this is what we're doing.
Yes,
that's perfect.
That is literally then isn't it?
That this is not to resist your reality
and I don't think that means becoming
some doormat that people can walk all
over,
but when you are in a traffic jam is the
perfect example of a situation over
which you have no control in this
moment.
You get an angry cannot influence or
determine that situation in any way and
then I think that if you can,
once you've realized it on a mundane
level of traffic jam our far,
can you extrapolate that?
You know when someone goes,
I'm in love with someone else,
I'm leaving you.
Oh,
okay.
How long have you speak to that tolle?
Do you know that guy got tall,
we wrote know he speaks like this.
Here's a German person Auntie so
relaxed.
He can barely talk to some mistakes,
some glitch in the matrix.
I managed to get his phone number right.
Oh Geez.
I have to ask you to stop calling me.
I'm changing my
now,
but it was meant to be for one
interview,
but then I thought,
fuck me,
I've got access to this Buddhist guy.
I'm going to tap.
It pisses me off.
I call it go,
what do I know?
You're lucky.
I've started to lot,
but beyond
that there's nothing that can be done
for you.
It was really.
It was fascinating.
Told you because I was like,
I was having a hard time with a woman
that was seen and am I going to do and
she's done listening.
She's done that and he goes,
world,
perhaps you would resolve this conflict
and you will become married and you will
have children and then both of you will
die.
She was just like,
you're just like.
Because he knows that actually you are.
You're gonna die.
That's the end point really.
So like an hour over wherever you invest
your energy,
be fully well aware that at some point
is going to be really good.
Yeah,
it might work out or death,
but definitely death.
Death.
How many hours does it take to get to
Boston?
A up three hours,
40 minutes or so.
So we're in the middle.
We're in the middle.
It depends where you lead from the
middle and if you don't drive like my
mother and father would make me aware
that we're going to be dead.
How'd you man?
And my mom.
My mom would always say,
I'm going to be dead one day,
so you need to this,
this,
this and that.
And it would,
it would.
I couldn't handle that.
She made,
I want to say I was still alive
five to seven,
you know,
five years old.
She introduced Jim to the concept of
mortality,
five to seven.
I was still struggling with a goldfish
concept that goldfish gone,
oh,
don't worry.
Isn't that a good idea?
To start those thoughts off?
Really,
let's accept this and get over these
goddamn things.
Let's figure out what the fuck.
We're so terrified above that we have to
create a land in the clouds that were
definitely all going to go to a meet up
after the fucking show,
but that,
that,
that put me in check of the whole thing,
get it.
I got to say,
and it,
it,
it made me sob.
Just the thought of where we going,
where are we going?
What happens is just are we just,
is it just blackness like gluten and my
and my father towards the end,
he just.
Lily went,
yeah.
He said your dad and that's.
I said,
show goes on and it's simple as that.
Evelyn.
Oh my God,
I forgot about that past
blake.
I'm not down with that one.
I mean like listen,
the cloud kingdom.
But the thing is Joe,
you know,
before we moved to Oakland about your
dmt experiences in new said,
it will be like a sort of a cave man
with a cran trying to draw,
draw God right now,
even on campus or maybe very
specifically said it.
You can rewind the podcast.
You can listen to it again.
That's what Joe said,
right?
I think you said your fingers were
stubby.
I don't want to be in that particular.
Right,
so like it when people talk about,
you know,
when like,
like you know,
the Kingdom of Heaven is within or you
know,
in the afterlife there'll be 72 virgins.
Me Personally,
I see these things,
his metaphors.
It will be as if you will be in such a
blissful state when you are free of the
shackles of the material realm when you
are liberated from your body.
I spent,
oh,
how's this is this isn't nothing sort of
makes me look good and maybe it makes me
look sandwich.
I was doing one of my base of altruism.
Never Day,
you know,
like our doll out.
Bits of altruism.
I told you I already mentioned going to
a homeless place today if you're picking
it up.
I'm a pretty nice guy.
I was at this other place that was a
like a adult learning difficulties
place.
Right?
And for me the term learning
difficulties was polite because these
people were like,
you know,
fucking seriously mentally ill.
I mean,
I'm like,
you know what I mean?
That was beautiful human beings and
everything,
but like,
well anyway,
there was not.
I had a really fantastic time there and
of course it made me feel incredibly
grateful for my own life and all the
things one would imagine that you'd feel
in such a situation most and now
chatting to the people and one person
was like,
people get very certificates for various
kinds of achievements,
whether it was in the art art doing some
joins or whether it was doing some
cooking or whatever.
And like I started to feel the impulse
of sort of a bit of patronizing this of
like,
oh,
okay,
and that certificate.
Oh yeah.
And then I for a minute,
this ain't no fucking different from
someone who's doing a full year.
I in religion,
in global politics really.
I mean,
if you can imagine supreme
consciousness,
if you could imagine the realms
experienced on dmt or the realms that
have been described with people that
have dedicated themselves to meditation
or Kundalini of Datasat,
cade themselves.
But you know,
Terence Mckenna get into them,
super states of consciousness accessible
to individuals and our birth right.
Some people say that our little
achievements have I got myself a
Giraffe,
for example,
a new car or the things that I'm proud
of today.
We similarly over on this little
pedestrian level in a lot with sweet
little darling things.
Really with our material achievements,
with our accolades and awards and it,
it changed my perspective of it,
of like bloody hell.
The difference between me and someone
that's not in the.
What would you consider being the normal
Straw of the mental health field?
It's no real.
It's not that bloody different.
Not In infinite space.
Not with Jupiter sucking in meet yours.
Oh,
that shit going on right now.
What's the difference between me and
someone that's,
you know,
life is confined to sort of cooking
projects.
It's not hugely significant except I'm
not that good at cooking in a way there,
but I never got asked.
Well,
it might not be hugely significant in
your perspective when you look at the
infinite,
but it's very significant in terms of
the two of you are relating to each
other and trying to work this life out
and trying to be sort of a compatible
try to communicate,
try to be friendly with each other and
work out all the weird cultural
differences between everybody and try to
get to the essence of what it means to
be a person and we're all going through
some weird sort of struggle.
No one escapes the struggle.
Not even Johnny Depp.
Even jade time,
believe in Johnny.
Johnny Depp got dragged into the Golden
Triangle of pussy problems and he's in
there right now.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
You didn't care.
He did the rock star.
Did this happen during the rock store?
Didn't you hear this recently?
He's getting.
His girlfriend said he beat her and he's
saying he's saying his girlfriend,
his fucking Doug standups getting sued
because he wrote a whole article saying
that he's really good friends with
Johnny Depp and Doug Stanhope wrote an
article about how the woman is a been
blackmailing johnny and threatening him
and he brought it up before the.
The whole thing came out in the news
that she had certain demands.
If you didn't reach UNOS,
who's fucking right and who's wrong?
Correct.
But at the end of the day,
you know,
whether Johnny telling them the truth or
not,
but at the end of the day,
even Johnny Depp can escape to fucking
pussy problems.
The reality of the world,
you know,
he's boring.
I said he's,
I think for the first time in life he
said he would,
you would see him with images of
rockstars and he loved.
But now he's touring.
So he's doing what?
Cooper and a.
But yes,
he went on a rock tour.
It's like I'm telling you,
it's cooper selling hot dogs in Arizona.
Not Dude,
I'm telling you,
look it up there.
But they were like,
cause I get a name.
They stood a rock tour and I went,
Huh?
Johnny Depp it.
And they did a lot of cities and maybe
he's.
Wow.
That's the one thing he didn't get out
of a system.
I don't even think that's it,
man.
I just think Johnny Depp is just being
Johnny Depp 70.
Good God damn time.
But like this all the time.
What's it called?
The Hollywood vampires.
Vampires.
Johnny Depp is the guitarist.
Wow.
That's pretty bad ass.
That's Johnny Depp over there on the far
right.
With a goofy hat or is it a if I left
with a goofy hat?
Yeah.
Wow.
Good for him.
Johnny Depp's live in a goddamn
exemplary life.
And I think that's Joe Perry on the
right.
That is Alice motherfucking cooper.
Look at that at all.
He's been selling hot dogs and fucking
Arizona has some cooper dog or alice has
dogs place.
He was a radio DJ in Phoenix too.
He had a radio show.
He's addicted.
He got to see.
He goes to movies and he only sees
those.
He only sees the premieres and then he
goes on the street.
People like this is the first time he
sort of like hundreds of death.
It was a big difference between.
Oh,
so you're trying to say that he isn't
doing shows is this brought him to a
high heat and he pried it?
No,
he's probably having a ball,
but I'm not saying that this happened,
but maybe it could be that simple.
He,
that's Ah,
that's a big high boy.
I just stood on the stage.
You'd go nuts.
I was like,
the only time that you're allowed to
dress like that.
You can't dress like that.
And really you have to go on stage to
dress up like that.
Go,
go to those,
some of those photos.
If you come over my house with the
fucking leather pants on and a shirt
like that,
I'll fucking choke.
You can't come in my house like that.
What are you doing man?
Why are you dressing like you just came
over on a boat from Spain?
Some Cell Toro risks being taken that
he's got laser on his wrists,
but you can pull that off if you're in a
band.
Look at him,
but he always dresses like that.
It's like he's wearing his regular
clothes.
Like for Johnny Depp.
He's wearing regular clothes,
but he does have his sleeves rolled up
and see what I mean.
Sort of expectation for sure.
He's definitely working on that image.
Do you think he must've hair up on
purpose?
Like not Masiya enough.
Come on,
sit up a little more.
Spray.
Listen there,
stick it up.
Hey listen.
I know more power to them.
I want to do that too.
Just wanting to go to Germany just like
Ryan Paik I think can just go to
Germany.
You'd probably just.
I could just do that too.
Yeah.
There is no one wants to stage and
entering gentlemen.
Him value freight to go it tied in lace
if you choose that you would looking at
in,
in his.
His situation is whether he's navigating
it successfully or not.
He's definitely in a strange path of the
river.
You know,
he's in a strange,
really deep wide channel.
Would incredible rapids and he's riding
on a fucking inner tube down the stretch
of river that nobody gets to ride.
The Johnny Depp stretches like Tom
Cruise stretch or the Samuel Jackson
stretch.
Like,
whoa.
Like these motherfuckers can't go
anywhere.
Like,
yeah,
Stan Hope told me.
Hangs around with Johnny Depp and they
can't go anywhere.
They have dudes with earpieces
everywhere.
There's people constantly circling him,
making sure he's okay and he'll go into
a restaurant.
There's people that are guarding the
doors.
They're watching the.
They're making sure people don't go in
the room.
It's very,
very different than even regular fame.
He's in that pirates of the Caribbean
fame where it's just can't go anywhere.
That's an expensive product,
bro.
I need to protect that product.
Well,
it's also,
he's super vulnerable,
like people lose their fucking minds and
they're around a certain level of
celebrity.
Does it?
Tom Cruise,
Tom Cruise can't go to the movies.
He's get it.
If you went to the movies,
he would leave the movie theater and
people will be trying to grab him as he
was walking in the theater just to touch
him and take pictures with them and it's
not like you can't just interact with
people,
right.
Identify only Tom Cruise.
It's an intense experience.
What was that like?
What'd you do?
It was a film called rock of ages that
Baldwin,
lots of freely,
freely famous people were in it and the
monkey and the monkey when already where
there was no monkey in it and at some
point Tom Cruise said there's going to
be a monkey in his film,
and from that point there was a fucking
monkey in the film.
Even Mass Ada monkey was in scenes that
Tom cruise weren't in one with me and
the monkey was an asshole.
It was wearing a nappy that was tied on
with electric tape.
It was very aggressive.
It jumped off of the shoulder.
The guy that was meant to be looking
after the monkey,
the monkey had a trailer with five other
monkeys in it.
It could fuck in its time off was
getting the monkeys fucking contract.
He wouldn't have to him.
You can say there's a scene with the
monkey.
I didn't know acting at.
All I'm doing is he's just a man
nervously looking at.
I'm just thinking that thing down off
that shoulder at any point now.
Fuck you up.
It could fuck.
Well Thomas Tom Cruise.
He likes traveling king,
you know,
like he's got many,
many trailers like and like so like you
know you arrive in a situation you think
rock era.
My prejudices about Tom Cruise,
all the things I've read,
all the things I've heard go prejudice.
Like we meet him,
he blasted me.
We've searched affability and charm that
they melt it away.
Ice cones.
Then the pure hate of the man.
Sweetness.
You gave a lock on the sofa.
It was my birthday.
During that film I got a big basket full
of black yoga related things and stuff
like that.
They sort of fought for president.
You remember?
You know,
shake your hand.
Remembers your name,
sort of remembers details about eggs.
I could brief.
You mentioned you're on a or something
into compensation.
Next conversation.
You mentioned that on A.
I went round.
His house for dinner was really,
really late because of that fucking
monkey.
Actually it was playing up.
A lucky was not working that day.
I went back,
went mandy's affidavit,
said when he'd been married,
Katie Holmes,
and there's that little famous Tom
Cruise.
Siri Cruz was.
They're all lined up.
I went there.
I was very,
very late and they'd like the Ada wheat
and he goes,
oh,
well do you want to still eat?
I went,
yeah,
no,
I wait and I had to sat like I'm sitting
with you now.
Joe Opposite Tom Cruise and Katie Holmes
and the little dial in one.
I was fucking in spaghetti like and it's
as a complicated thing to eat
long,
isn't it?
I was telling me that a lady and the
tramp shoving that shit in and then the
next course I think was the signer,
which was weird because that's to pass
the courses.
Then I think there was like sort of
cupcakes and stuff involved all the way
through.
It just sat opposite.
Tom Cruise silicon about communism,
which I brought up as a topic,
which in retrospect was a mistake.
Why?
Well,
because don't bring up communism because
I like what I said was our goes,
well,
I'm down with fairness where I goes,
you know,
communism.
Yeah.
Surely it went a bit.
It got a bit out of control.
No one's arguing with that.
Went a bit hectic.
I'm not down with massacres.
Genocides under one flag,
but fairness and justice I'm fully up
for.
And Tom Cruise goes out.
Data about that.
The communism.
Marco's.
Yeah.
But Tom,
you were born with this thing.
You've been born with this thing.
I guess that's like being born an Irish.
The crap,
you know,
like the thing that you've got that
drive or wherever,
you know,
your,
like people aren't like you.
I try to explain it to Tom,
but uh,
it was hard for him to take me
seriously.
Speaker eight,
amateur.
But I had a good go of saying it's
probably different to be Tom cruise than
other people.
Yeah,
for sure.
But what,
what,
what was he saying?
That the communism is a bad idea.
And you were saying that,
you know,
maybe sharing more would be a good idea.
Isn't it weird that communism is
connected to dictatorships,
which is kind of the opposite of
communism.
It really is.
I think if anything,
as soon as people start to implement
ideas,
it gets in fucking trouble,
doesn't it?
Because people started.
People put Lauer.
Nicole.
Yeah,
the power of course.
Because all of these political ideas and
religious art is exposed to just be,
we're here,
we're going to die,
or should we try and make it as nice as
possible?
And like part of that is going to be not
been out of order to each other and like
in a sort of like and buy all of them
interface with our problems,
the problems.
We have described those biological
mechanical drive.
So I'm trying out a lot.
All I said is like the communism there
is socialism and communism and
communism.
That's different from the depiction of
communism that a lot of Americans and
English people would have because we
were.
We were on the other side of the Cold
War.
So we got a very,
very negative impact.
And of course that was a version of
communism.
It was pretty fucking brutal in places
as is capitalism,
you know.
So I'm sort of like trying to kick
around these.
I was saying like,
yeah,
but really all communism is,
is a sort of a version of Christianity
in that it's saying we are all brothers
here and all of us have riots and we
should be trying to build a society
where we love each other.
That's sort of what he's saying,
you know,
like,
where it goes wrong is it doesn't allow
room for individualism and the many
myriad distinctions between different
human beings by one concentrate on that,
but that's not really communism or that
it's really more of dictatorships.
That was dictatorship.
So you can dress it up.
It won't because like,
yeah,
that's the.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean like,
you know,
I'm not a scholar in communism,
otherwise I'm going to do a degree in
religion and global politics.
And for me,
I'm going to spend the next three years
doing it.
Part time you,
you have to pop in a day and that week.
And actually have not done it yet.
Go go for the interview next week.
I'm hoping they're going to let me in.
Just on the basis of.
C'Mon.
Let me in the fucking Tele.
Give us a break.
Anyway,
so I'm there anyway,
but my point,
my point I was trying to make is that
things get convoluted and complicated
by,
you know,
bureaucracy,
ideology and demagoguery.
But ultimately we're just meant to be
sharing and sort as bloody community.
Really.
The dictatorship aspect of it is almost
like,
it's almost like that same inescapable
drive that causes someone to want to be
the monkey with the five monkeys did a
good fucking time.
There's only so long going,
I'm going to be the monkey.
That's fucking fine.
Wherever it's like any sort of religious
extremism,
there's always some guy at the end of it
go and I'm going to
be fucking five monkeys in my trailer
and then that person's ruining it for
the rest of us.
Because like whenever you see like about
religious coal in it,
you know,
I've started a religious cult,
we all live here together and we grow
around vegetables.
Everything's organic.
Yeah.
Alright.
That's lovely mate.
Oh,
you fucking everyone.
I done against that a little bit.
Yeah,
a little bit.
I've got a monkey trailer.
Everybody else's wives.
Yeah.
That's.
That's one of those weird,
inescapable things about being a person
who did these.
These drives that you have to figure out
how to hold them together.
I think communism would work.
Look,
if this was a community,
if we,
if we were the only four people on an
island,
just us four,
we would be communists.
We would all just get together and we
would talk like,
how do you guys want to handle this?
Like what do we do?
How do we gather this?
I'm pulling off.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm,
I'm pretty good at climbing trees under
where the coconuts are.
Okay,
cool.
And we'd figure it out.
Share poems cause only provide those,
but we will lose our share.
Right?
And if we didn't,
we'd have to have a conversation.
We'd have to say,
hey joe,
you're not fucking digging enough holes
or you don't catch enough fish.
We gotta we gotta work this out
together.
So we all contributed in equal amount.
You can't be lazy and exist off the
fruits of your brothers and sisters.
Labor.
It's really good.
It's all contribute.
What's difference between that and being
tribal?
It's the same thing.
Same thing.
Have you heard this thing?
The inner chimpanzee societies,
they have about 75 chimps.
Ryan,
once it gets to about eight or nine a
things get edgy and they normally break
off and go a breakaway chimp community
because this is getting too heavy over
here and so the assumption is that we,
as you know,
great apes ourselves similarly should be
living in manageable communities.
We serve over stimulate new exposure.
You know,
when you were sort of joking about like
the power of women and femininity,
you're not meant to be exposed to that
kind of stuff.
You're not meant to meet that exposed to
that kind of imagery that is present in
pornography.
You don't mean to be exposed to that
kind of that kind of variety.
Women to be like,
there's 50 or 60 of us.
Alright,
these people,
good warriors.
These people are good fishermen.
These people look at it.
I mean mysticism,
you know,
you find little roles in it,
but again,
since we've lived in this mono culture
where people are like little cells,
batteries,
all sort of stacked up together in
cities and suburbs.
Then like how do you access that we're
not having an authentic human
experience,
so that's why there's so much.
So what do I want to say?
Disease,
what's an authentic human experience,
but it's a very new one.
It's a very different thing and I've,
I've tried to figure out what it is
we're actually doing,
but it seems to me that everything is
getting more and more connected.
Right?
So what we're doing when these cities is
we're connecting 20 million people into
this massive buildings and then we're
connecting them all with the Internet.
So they weren't connecting those 20
million people with 10 million people in
this state and 5 million people in that
state.
And we're,
we're all becoming one sort of weird
gigantic group that's very,
very dissimilar from the original tribal
groups that allowed one alpha male to
run things.
One Alpha female community.
Everybody knowing and understanding each
other.
And when you,
when you talk like archeologists
and have you ever read sex at dawn?
Dr Chris Ryan,
really interesting book,
but what he maintains is that this idea,
even of monogamy that didn't exist in
these tribal cultures,
they shared sexuality like everybody's
swapped around and people banged
everybody and that's one of the reasons
why they stayed intimate is that they
all probably were polyamorous,
polyamorous,
and they didn't understand they will
steal.
It speaks to our nature because we don't
want to be monogamous.
It's a struggle.
But the polyamorous thing also speaks to
this idea that before we understood
genetics and we understood DNA,
we didn't know whose children they were.
So if you had a child,
if a woman had a child and I fucked her
and you fucked her and you fucked her,
we'll assume it's our kid.
We don't.
No one knows.
They didn't understand it.
They didn't know once.
It will mail and clues along the way.
For sure.
Definitely people get it.
They figured it out after a while that
kids struggling a little paypal.
But that's a weird thing too,
is how children maintain some sort of
talent traits that their parents have.
Like there's things that get passed on
through children to,
through DNA of obsessive behaviors come
like a desire to grow and learn.
People like have kids that are very
similar in personality that seemed to be
like inherent to the child that seems to
come through the DNA.
If it wouldn't,
wouldn't that be a little bit to have
the kid that's only knows growing up and
he's,
if he's watching maybe a parent that's
obsessive,
he's either going to not be in that or
I'm going to be.
I'm sure it's possible.
It's totally possible.
But there's also like a pattern that
they follow.
Like um,
my middle daughter is obsessed with
things.
She gets obsessed with things.
Like she's read six Harry Potter books.
She's eight.
She's keeps reading them.
She'll read hours and hours every night.
And then she also wants to talk about
Harry Potter.
She's all fucking totally.
Harry Potter it out.
Like all day long she will explain
something,
man.
I'm like,
is that Harry Potter thing?
She was like,
yes it is.
And then she'll,
she'll,
she's just obsessed with Harry Potter or
gymnastics or whatever the fuck it is.
She's very much like me.
When she gets something,
she just doing cartwheels in the living
room all day long and fucking backhand
springs.
She never stops.
She's just obsessed and she gets on
these things and just ride them out and
she doesn't even necessarily know that
that's how I am.
I don't think she sees that because I'm
not like that when I'm around her.
Really.
So you observing her and it's the same
extent.
Oh Wow.
She's got my eyes.
You can see she's exhibiting traits.
She's not been taught.
They're very extreme.
It's very extreme.
It's not like a,
Oh,
it's similar because my youngest
daughter is just silly.
She's not like that at all.
She's,
she's not obsessive at all.
She just a fun little kid.
But the middle one is kind of fucking
crazy.
Does that.
How does that,
does that make you feel like different
type of connection?
No,
no,
no.
This is the connection with all of them.
That's interesting thing about having
children.
The connection with all of them is just
so spectacular.
It's not a,
there's not like I connect with this one
more than that one,
connect with all of them.
But um,
it's interesting to observe your own
bizarre personality traits manifesting
themselves almost in a genetic level.
Kid.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
my middle one's like that.
My middle one is identical twin.
Me and I sometimes I like it.
Sometimes I love it and sometimes they
go,
oh,
I like that.
How old is she?
She's 14.
So she's really blossoming.
But you know what?
The one that does all the gymnastics and
all that.
I noticed too with kids,
they express happiness in different
ways.
My oldest one,
the only time I know she's truly happy
and she's 17 now,
is when she's bouncing,
singing,
doing a cartwheel outside.
She kind of instrument.
That's when she's silent.
I go,
Oh man,
something's up.
This kid's been silenced or turned dad.
So expressive.
You know,
also when you think about it,
like who,
who's like more expressive than you,
like you're this like joyful guy who was
always get this crazy laugh and you
know,
by now at 14,
she's super aware that you play these
places all over the world.
People come to see you and laugh.
I mean,
that's got to be bizarre to what does it
mean?
What does your dad do for a living?
Oh,
I fixed the pipes.
What about your dad just talks shit in
front of people and they left their dick
off.
You know,
it's a very bizarre thing for a kid to
go,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
You can do that too,
right?
You know,
and they see that and then you know,
and also I'm sure you're not restrictive
in how they express themselves.
You probably want them to have fun and
laugh and joke around a lot.
Yeah.
I mean,
so that gets encouraged and then I think
happiness,
like self reflection and all these other
things,
these,
it's a,
these are muscles and you can work on
those muscles.
You know,
you can,
you can develop them.
I think you're absolutely right about
that.
I,
they,
it,
I've been using these circuits,
leather,
if you login,
how it must be neurologically.
Of course I'm speculating about
neurology,
which is probably not something that
someone who knows nothing about you,
none of us do.
So we'll just follow you on
the uh,
the,
you know,
if you're continually activate in
certain neurological pathways or
creating relationships,
synaptic relationships,
then that,
that's going to fire up more readily.
I mean,
I notice it with some of these new
things I'm doing,
like initially when people were
explaining stuff about getting out of
off guard and lighten how even to
shuffle on the floor,
you know,
that shrimp is.
I said I ain't ever going to be.
I do this sooner.
So flat.
It seems like it's making its way
behaviorally into a different aspect of
my consciousness.
And I suppose if there's like in a wind
to happiness or misery or addiction,
if you're continually living in that
circuit,
like,
you know,
people talk about programming I feel
like,
but when I'm aware of my programming,
is there certain things that if people
say them to me,
I can't help the reaction that I have,
you know,
obvious ones,
a citizen.
If I'm exposed to certain sexual images,
Bang,
I feel all those feelings before I make
any decisions.
If someone makes me feel insecure or say
something,
we'll have to really watch that moment
before because otherwise before now I've
gone down a path of behavior and I think
that what the perhaps what we can do on
an individual level is learn.
And this is not hard for people are
living in total fucking crisis and
dreadful poverty in the.
You said before,
I'm personally,
I'm in a privileged position where I can
begin to bring my consciousness to those
kinds of things,
right?
I want to live on that circuit.
Now.
I don't want to always have Nikki
judgments.
I,
I'm always want to feel fearful when
these moments,
I want to learn to plow that
neurological pathway so that it's easier
for me to stay there,
that you know programming is necessary
and like if you're not living on a
program that you've taken control of
individually,
you're living on someone else's program,
you're living on that program that's out
there,
that constant bombardment of negativity
and fear and anxiety and division and
you're different from paypal and you're
not good enough and by this otherwise
you're not going to be good enough.
You know that you're going to need
pretty strong defenses.
I think that's why with the diminished
role of religion in our life with the
diminished role of sort of political
ideologies that we can trust.
What are people supposed to do about
being alive and not feeling good or who
do you go to now
doing it?
I think you were part of it.
I think there's a lot of other people
that are doing it too.
It's like you're trying to reexamine the
patterns that you're stuck in and how
many of these patterns that you or I or
Jim or anybody here,
it's created for themselves.
You've created a lot of your own prison
bars and that's a really common thing
with people.
You know,
these whatever defenses that you've put
up,
whatever the patterns that you've
instinctively followed because of
jealousy or fear of inadequacy or any
weird feelings,
you've set these neurological patterns
and they're very difficult to break once
you've set them yourself.
It's almost like you've built your own
prison and now you're complaining about
it.
Yes,
I agree with this.
Now that,
do you think we could introduce to that,
uh,
kind of a compassion because,
you know,
when we're earlier on,
we're talking about like we can
understand people who sort of jealousy
or irritation like people being famous
or rich because I,
there's no doubt there's too much
inequality,
this,
too much injustice.
It's not something that can really be
questioned.
And so when,
what I'm trying to do is bring bloody
compassion and tolerance to places where
I find it odd today someone was like,
you know,
I told you I didn't bring no club.
I left my suitcase,
I fucked up,
you know,
so it's going in the shop and this is
gonna.
This is a problem of great privilege.
I went along to a pretty cool shop in
Los Angeles and their security fellow at
goes shopping open yet.
Then he recognized me and he goes,
oh no,
no,
their shop is open.
Right?
And the.
And I was like,
oh,
thank you mate.
And I felt all special for a moment.
Then we got to the doorway to shop and
the guy that was inside the shop,
he,
I don't know,
he's having a bad day or whatever.
And he goes,
oh,
you know,
maybe you can't come in.
Right?
And I made it for you.
Fucking like the reaction.
I feel like rage actually.
And in the security guy to his eternal
credit overrode the guy in the right
now.
And just let him in,
let him in,
in Laos got in the shop.
And I felt sort of like I felt better
about myself in that moment.
Like,
I'm so special,
I'm allowed.
It had so many little things sort of
triggered in me in that sort of short
momentary interaction and feeling of
like,
oh great.
The security guy recognizes me.
Oh No,
this guy,
they let me in.
And it's very hard for me actually.
It says I'm still in my mind judging
that guy that they wouldn't let me in
and around in my consciousness fucking
pumps.
You still have an argument in your head,
should say
that,
that would have destroyed him.
That guy
told the perfect thing like a silver
bullet and then you get there.
And he goes,
hey man,
I'm really sorry if I was rude earlier,
I just,
uh,
my girlfriend broke up with the perfect
thing.
And then you will go to
support guys working retail girlfriends.
Fucking some football player.
Poor bastard,
right?
Does your mom is too?
Are you going to club and you're so
fucking rude.
I thought in my mad success I'd reached
to the point where I can walk to a place
in the city.
You're not allowed in here and I turn
around,
I'm going fucking,
I'm going to buy this fucking place and
then I'm going to fire.
That's how fucking work.
That's what Tom Cruise does.
So Tom,
the new
place said a lot of admin just to
maximize net.
You've got to go for.
All right.
Okay.
The surveyors are coming on Monday
gauge,
right?
Jesus Christ.
50 people coming to check right now.
Could you bring a.
suddenly we can't bring in Dave because
he's a chemotherapy session.
Can we might have some weird laws or who
you could fire and not foreign.
Imagine now you buy the building.
This fuck has to keep working for you.
Oh my God.
Now you're stuck with him and then he
sues you for discrimination or
harassment or something like that.
Dave was missing a tone when I tried to
sack him.
That was a misstep.
Wasn't mistake in retrospect.
So did anybody from the Tom Cruise camp
try to convert?
You know,
one might even the remote is the effort
to convert me.
I couldn't have made it more clear that
was desperately in need of an ideology
gets funded.
It was something to believe in some
structure,
so just for Fuck Sake,
give me that dialectics book,
whatever it's called.
Yeah,
there should be a way.
Right.
I was not interested.
It's like Joe,
I felt.
I thought they felt that I would ruin so
until the tree.
And they did.
They did.
They didn't.
There was no invitation,
but no one said,
come on mate,
you need a biff l,
Ron Hubbard in your life.
There was no,
no interest.
They might have been an expansionist
religion.
No one up at all,
and if ever there was a candidate for a
religion,
I think they tread very carefully on
those waters.
You have to start asking questions
yourself
or there's certain levels.
Perhaps this is also possibly where they
don't necessarily really want anybody
fucking thought,
no,
I didn't qualify.
I'm going to that fucking slippery
center.
I'm going to kick the bloody door and
say,
come on.
I think type.
My mother had been burned too many times
up.
They're very careful about who they
allow in,
who they don't allow,
and I would imagine that pillorying of
science,
I'm always feel sorry for me.
Well,
they're just trying their hardest to
make up a religion.
I mean,
I don't know.
I just see going clear.
Yeah,
that was.
You'll stop feeling sorry for him.
When you watch going clear,
you like,
what in the fuck?
I like that Guy Paul Haggis who went
like when they showed him,
right?
This is your scripts.
He was like,
he looked around for the outcome and
this is the test right to people.
If you believe in this,
they go,
no,
you fucking market.
That's not the real thing.
You immediate get out.
Well,
he was a madman.
I mean l Ron Hubbard,
whether or not he's correct about
scientology wrote more fiction than any
person that's ever lived.
Even if that was his only qualification,
he was just making stuff and making
stuff up and then he wrote this and no
red flags.
No one,
no one goes,
hey,
maybe made this up to no fucking chance.
On Monday is in Guinness.
World Records for making shit up on
Tuesdays he starts to religion and no
one goes,
is this connected to Monday's activity
in any way?
Not only that,
just a chronic liar.
Just his whole life was just full of
shit.
Oh.
So I didn't like.
He's rubbery wet lips like Ronald
Mcdonald mouth.
It was a little bit of a global sort of
like sort of wet slobbery guy on those
fucking cruise ships dressing people up.
I mean,
I'm not a big fan of dudes with captains
outfits on him and
what he did,
he was in the navy and he did command
ships apparently.
But he was apparently a pretty good at
that shit.
He was removed from his duty.
But the point is after he got out
decided I'm still rocking this captain's
outfit go,
fuck.
They will believe anything's how I
crossed me.
I got a boat,
I'm going to make some shit up and I'll
have them for quite a and make a good
business of watch me areas.
Yeah.
I skipper madman,
look it at fascinating and the liquid
around the mouth,
I suppose people that are scientologists
was say,
this is our religion and uh,
you're taking the piss out of our
region.
It's an ideology that is also a very
positive one in the sense that it's
dedicated towards self improvement.
And eliminating all these psychological
barriers that are holding you back and
in that way people find a lot of benefit
in being a part of that religion and I
think when they find a lot of benefit
and being a part of it,
then you know they can justify all the
other nonsense and just sort of ignore
it because what l Ron Hubbard,
according to the going clear book,
Lawrence Krauss Book was trying to do
with self medicate,
would he?
He had a lot of psychological issues
himself and he was trying to cure his
own issues and in using these methods to
cure his own religion or the zone,
his own issues,
he translated them into a religion.
Like this was a big part of what
scientology initially was,
was his own attempts to self diagnose
and treat his own psychological
ailments.
Quite a good idea really works really
well.
And there are so I suppose people there,
it's working for all right.
Like a quote I heard,
I'd like to be quick to see where
religious people are,
right?
You know,
it's all really August where religious
people are wrong because we sort of hear
about it on news,
but like
w we're religious people are right,
you know,
sort of togetherness,
selfless nurse relationship with a
deeper self acceptance of death and the
possibility of transcendence of the
human primal self.
Those things are all really beautiful
ideas that they've kind of lost their
way in a science,
a science,
you know,
that term.
Scientism,
the idea that sort of science has got
into territories that science can really
handle because we come to a judging full
stop at certain points.
You know,
like what happened on the Tuesday before
the Big Bang,
you know,
serialism
materialism,
individualism
are hard things to overcome.
If like,
if,
if people,
if we are,
if we have as our dominant mindset,
I'm only gonna believe shit that I can
prove.
Then you are just an individual and you
may as well just.
Why not just spend your life fuck as
many people as you can and accumulating
as much material as you can because
nothing exists.
Unless you can see it,
measure it,
why it contain it and fuck it.
You know,
if that is the dominant belief system,
which was sort of materialism,
consumerism,
capitalism,
I think all dovetail on that premise.
This is all real.
That's how you can have the,
the chronic ecological disrespect is
because it really doesn't matter what
happens after you're dead.
There you go,
well,
what about my fucking children?
Even just not a practical level of
called live on this fucking pebble in
infinite space.
But if you're just like,
well,
not really thought about that in a sort
of an inability to accept,
you know,
like certain.
I know that you're sort of like a
wholesale by any dominant theory,
but I think it's clear to me that
general,
well,
I believe in on an individual level and
on a cultural level,
if something is possible,
you should be trying to fucking do it.
So as soon as people realize,
hold on a minute,
that's having a negative impact,
or hey,
this is a better way of using our
resources.
Now utilities,
soon as you realize it,
you should be moving towards it.
They say wisdom is acting on knowledge.
Once you recognize,
oh,
fossil fuels are running out so right
fucking hell,
we'd better start working on the basis
that we're fucked.
We better start looking at alternative
energy sources.
We're looking at different alliances
like knowing those things and not doing
them.
It makes me very,
very uneasy because it makes me think
who benefits from ignoring this stuff?
Who's running this show?
If he's having all of the.
It's creating all this rage,
all this unease,
all this fear in your country and in my
country now times of great,
great disease and uncertainty for people
really looking for something and know
that these institutions are just saying,
just united carry on.
There's no sort of alternative.
No one's going to let you know is going
to see himself as part of a religious
community in the same way or so.
One of the dead ideologies of the last
century and meanwhile we're in this sort
of peculiar style of looming crisis.
It feels kind of fucking mad
in a state of looming crisis,
but to unpack this whole thing,
you started off with this idea of what
happened the Tuesday before the Big Bang
and how science can't really answer that
well,
they can't answer it yet.
Like the problem is once they gather
data,
it might be 100 years now or a thousand
years from now.
They can say,
Oh,
well here we've done the calculations
and we understand now that it's an
infinite cycle of birth and death and
the universe is constantly expanding
contracting and this is the process that
we're a part of.
It's infinite and it's never started.
It is never ending and it goes on and on
and on.
I think you'll probably bloody right
mate.
I like that idea that you just espoused
is in 5,000 year old fucking document
called the upanishads.
Those ideas,
those ideas are there already.
So when we fucked off religion a hundred
years ago because it was causing too
much,
you know our sake,
we got.
We kicked out of some of the ideas that
are only now just being
discovered.
Right?
But those ideas are just to be
contemplated right now and to be
considered.
Whereas science is trying to find
definitive evidence that they do or
don't represent the reality of our
timeline.
And once they do,
then there'll be able to talk about it.
But right now what they're doing is
they're examining the evidence that the
big bang exists and what could have
possibly caused that.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
See what,
where what,
what my difficulty is is that there are.
That is when any ideology behaves
dogmatically and prohibitively prevent,
prevent further exploration,
like whatever that would like.
What kind of.
What's an example of it?
The nature of consciousness.
No one knows why consciousness impact
matter in the way it does in the sub
quantum world.
Now we can't fucking.
We've come to a point where it's like,
oh fuck.
Like you know,
like if you were like that,
the,
the famous double Slit Theory and
observed particle behaves differently
like the end of the park.
One way you can change it.
It's the central nature depending on
where he's been obsessed
presented though when it's been
explained to me by people actually
understand it.
What it really is is that we're
measuring these particles and in the act
of measuring,
you're changing the results because
you're using something to measure it.
Yes,
yes,
but it gets represented as all this woo
woo craziness,
but what?
What I think is interesting,
Joe,
is somewhere between this woo craziness
and they're kind of a flat,
mundane,
low.
This is life.
You're born,
you die,
you eat food.
Shit comes out your ass old territory,
somewhere in there is a mystery that
they're behind your eyes buying Jimbo,
Jamie's eyes and my eyes.
There is a constant.
There is this consciousness,
there is this awareness.
There's this inexplicably experience
that you've add on dmt experiences that
I've had through yoga and through lsd.
That suggests to me that consciousness
itself is the dominant force.
Consciousness is not just one more
phenomena is the seat of all phenomena
and when people are saying,
oh,
there's this thing,
that's God.
What they are saying is there is an
absolute consciousness and all is
contained within it all matter at some
point has come from consciousness.
These realms,
they're experienced true psychedelic or
extreme extreme,
you know,
personal experiments like if cryogenic
things or your flotation tanks all
suggest a phenomenon beyond the
individual consciousness.
They something else say and the very
fact that you know that it's in for the
consciousness,
even by the process of measuring,
even by the process of measuring is
influencing and impacting rally.
I don't think that,
you know,
I'm not taking that to the extreme.
I know what you mean.
Make some people go,
oh,
that means your mind can control shit.
And when I think it means that,
it means that reality is only reality.
When you look at it,
that's what it's kind of getting towards
a bloody good book.
I reckon your listeners will be banging
into his Kumbaya centuries in by a man
called Robert Lanza who he did the best
breakdown I've ever read of that double
slit experiment and,
and have the,
the,
you know,
made me understand for the first time
that reality is happening within your
own consciousness.
It's not an external phenomena at all
that you know,
like he explained it very wisely.
I could understand of like,
he went,
you know,
you sort of think I'm totally mundane.
He went like,
you know the experience of going in your
kitchen in the nine,
turning the light on.
Is your kitchen fridge still there when
you go back downstairs?
He goes,
well I guess when you do go into your
kitchen and turn the light on,
he goes to your Foa on parcels of
photons.
Come down,
I'd interact with the optic nerve.
They have a trans law.
They invert it in your consciousness
that you know,
so whatever it is,
what's in your kitchen when you're not
looking at it,
it ain't the same as when you are
looking at is an interpretive reality.
And one of the ways that I've sort of
reduced this down for my own simple
understanding is this,
that if none of us had a sense of smell,
if you didn't,
I'd been Jamie didn't.
And then how would the concept of smell
makes sense?
How would you go out with a pint and
this bike and with none of us would have
the instrument to receive it.
So that whole thing will be off the
agenda.
So I think that there are streams of
energy streams of data for which we do
not have the instruments to receive,
so we totally discount it because we
simply don't have the instruments to
receive it.
And I said once in my standup,
as a matter of fact,
like my cat doesn't know there's an
internet,
the internet does not enter the realm of
my cats consciousness,
but the fucking internet is out there.
We're out here.
Having with these fucking experiences
and like all those realms that we're
experiencing in these various sort of
psychedelic states or however they
achieved is an indication to me there's
another reality now.
Where does that become fucking relevant
to what we're talking about?
For me,
where it does,
he's one of the continual ideas that
keeps reemerging to connect us back to
where we were with Joe Campbell at the
beginning is there is this fucking sense
of oneness and believing ourselves to be
individual and believing that the
dominant thing in our lives to be
material that fucks us up because people
will kill each other over that material
and once we realized no with the true
thing about us is the consciousness is
the inner self.
That's the roofing they we're all out
here.
We're all in the game.
We're going to do shit and we're all
gonna make mistakes,
but that's not have the material idea as
the dominant social idea because
everyone's agreed with that.
Whether they're communist or capitalist
of fascist,
wherever everyone's saying now the main
thing is they ship this out here and
it's like that connects to those primal
drives because we know that if that's
happening to your sexual drive,
you can never have enough pussy.
If that gets into your state test drive,
you can never have enough status and
power,
you know,
so like we're all going to still feel
those things.
I'm still going to be a camp 25 times a
day,
but it'd be nice if the cultural
ambiance was,
oh,
I don't know who,
Russell,
you'll be back to your normal self in a
minute of feeling that we're all one and
we're all connected.
Not,
yeah,
well of course I'd feel right that you
know,
like that.
And that's what frightens me about the
culture of our countries at the moment
is it's endorsing the worst aspects of
our nature.
It's acculturating the worst aspects of
our nature instead of the best aspects
of our nature and that for me then I'm
fucking difference between left and
right in the current political sphere
because they're all making the same
argument.
They're all saying come and live out
here in the material world.
Yeah.
It seems to me that the material world
and this idea that we should be
accumulating possessions and status and
all these different things is universal.
It almost seems like it's a natural
progression from ancient tribal
civilization life to this weird city
life,
to this integration of electronics and
our life in this symbiotic relationship
that we have two computers and the
Internet and information itself.
It seems like this is one of the things
that drives.
That is this desire for material
possessions.
Because when you have a desire for
material possessions and ensures that
you're going to continue to innovate and
come up with newer and greater and
better because you always want to keep
up with the Joneses.
You always want to have the newest tesla
because it goes zero to 60 in two
seconds and you want to have the coolest
fucking house with the biggest TV and
the fastest internet and all those
things sort of compound this
technological innovation cycle that
we're on.
So my thought has been for a long time
that what we are is some sort of
electronic caterpillar that's going to
give birth some artificial life and that
all of our desire for material
possessions and status and all these
different things is really just us
pushing forth this electronic agenda and
that this innovation and the
construction of artificial intelligence
that's inevitable is eventually going to
be the next stage of life and that weird
like huddling ourselves up in this sort
of civilization cocoon and that boom out
of that cocoon is gonna pop.
Some sort of a god being and that this
is what we're here for and this is what
we've been doing since we're monkeys
flinging shit at each other and flipping
over cow patties,
looking for mushrooms.
That we are a part of a process.
And then if you look at it objectively,
all these traps that you or I or Tom
Cruise or Jim breuer been caught up in
when whether it's traps of Eagle or
jealousy.
All these things sort of ensure
movement.
They insure movement,
ensure interactivity,
and that is going to ensure innovation
and progress and competition.
And all those things that even we look
at it,
we go,
this is so pointless,
this is so foolish.
So but yet it's so incredibly prevalent.
Not Glorifying it or saying it's
definitely the way to go,
but objective Lee,
if you weren't a human and you're
stepping outside of this thing,
looking at it from a distance,
you're like,
these fuckers are making something they
might not even know they're making
something,
but they're making.
I understand
that the same way that bees or ants may
will be aware of their hive
consciousness and the and the common
drive.
But where I disagree with you,
Joe,
is that you see the end point as being
the materialization of a super
consciousness through technology.
I see the end point is being a
realization amongst us as a species.
Now I know that they're both could be
both and there is no.
There isn't a reason to,
you know,
we all just another fucking,
oh we just another species on this
planet.
Oh,
we will know better than dogs and cows
and monkeys.
I don't,
I,
you know,
we are.
If the sun that heats us up as a
lifespan,
where are their inventions as well?
The cats and the monkeys.
That's I'm fucking invented being cute.
I mean they're so real dollar in your
lap.
You pet them.
They like it.
They need to contribute.
They're contributing.
Take the dog for a walk.
You come up with ideas.
You're not spelling.
I'll do love my dog,
but hold on.
But my.
What was my.
What was my point in that?
Well,
I think you want to pump the brakes.
What you're saying is we should pump the
brakes.
We should pump the brakes of this
possession in this.
This idea that we're trying to
accomplish these great things by
accumulating things and status and it's
all bullshit and it's really about
consciousness more than anything.
In fact,
Bill Hicks,
I think already said it when he said
that,
you know,
that we can be explored.
We can explore space in an hour together
in peace.
That that idea that if we look to our
common drives,
it's like ended up at Hancock all the
time.
I've heard him on your show saying like
that.
Know what really what's happened is a
bias towards a particular aspect of our
own consciousness,
the problem solving brain and let you
know that those drives are amazing.
Those drugs they're trying to get
somewhere.
Technology is amazing.
We would like you to at the very fact
that people in bloody here is,
I don't understand any event.
It's fucking wonderful,
but the dominant idea behind it,
one of profit that dominating idea and
the profit in itself is not necessarily
negative but profit at all cost,
profit at any cost.
So really I'm not saying we should as a
species fucking slow down and dressing
fell and fucking,
you know,
like grab and vegetables.
It's funny now I want human beings to be
glorious,
but what I'm saying is that our bias
towards this one particular item,
materialistic idea,
is preventing us from realizing that
glory because part of our consciousness
has been ignored.
Yes,
but you from the time you want to say
yes,
but no,
no,
I think we all agree on that and I hate
to dumb it.
I'm dumb.
So dumb it down and I go back to pink
floyd.
We don't need no education.
It all we all aware you don't have a
chance where you check your back is
against the wall from the time you come
out of the womb because you're saturated
with false images.
You're saturated in our society.
God is money and success and there is no
soul.
They're in a too.
It takes people like you and I to go
there and go,
there's nothing doesn't fucking matter
because it's so oversaturated.
That's why the Kardashians are huge and
this person's huge and because it's
almost laughable because the more you
put it out there,
the harder they have to hit them on
their cell phones.
Well,
here's phones.
The kids
are going to be on a 24 slash seven.
It just,
it's massive overload.
It's the more your brain goes this way,
the more they go,
well,
we're not designed for this amount of
information coming in and that's for
sure.
Now we're not designed to be connected
with 7 billion people all over the
world.
We're not designed to seeing a camera
placed on someone that doesn't have
anything good to say.
Interesting.
Said,
oh,
but they're constantly on camera and
they're editing it in a way that you're
short attention span is sort of
connected to this thing because every 15
seconds of given you a new camera angle,
and that's by design.
It's like an interface.
They figured out how to do these reality
shows where they edit the show,
so like a music video where you're
constantly changing the angle so you're
constantly stimulated.
If you just had Kim Kardashians sitting
across the table from her mom and they
were just sitting there for like three
hours talking like a podcast,
you would want a fucking mediator to
come from Jupiter and slam right into
that God damn house and this now stop
this before it spreads.
What are they doing?
But if you keep them going back and
forth and then you cut to a single of
them by themselves.
Bitching about,
my mom has always been about blah,
blah,
and then go back to her.
Well,
she thinks that she can do this,
and then what am I shooting was,
wow,
look at that.
Watch premier cameras and constant
changing of angles and it's constant
fucking introducing of a new thing to
pay attention to.
I'm sorry,
on a stupid small note on a tiny,
tiny note of how powerful and how far my
oldest daughter and I,
I hate to admit it,
she sat there and her lips.
She came in the room and I told it 20
times,
don't do that.
She saw something on the Internet,
sticking her lips in the bottle and it
blows her lips up and for three days and
everyone's doing it and who wasn't?
That was mad at her.
I went,
wow,
this is how many my kids part of that
banana land.
It's just,
it's almost like they're laughing at us
now.
We couldn't make them do.
No one's pulling those strings.
We're pulling strings.
It's a visual.
Oh,
I see it and that's what I want to be.
Right?
Look at that image.
I know how many women want them in like
that shot into the Ras,
so they look like Kim Kardashian.
There's like a whole trend where women
are waist training where they're wearing
these corsets and tightening down there
fucking organs and then they're having
fat shoved into their ass.
They're extracting fat from areas of
their body and then reintroducing it
into their ass in order to develop this
round ridiculous thing that looks like
you're wearing a fucking diaper to be
relevant in to,
to imitate the same way.
You know,
the Siri women have fucking plates in
their lips were imitating patterns that
we see.
They don't necessarily have to make
sense,
but we're this weird animal that's sort
of imitates what our surroundings are.
We imitate our atmosphere and some
strange way and we can.
We can sort of create our own hell that
we,
you know,
we reproduce this thing around us that's
not just unsuccessful.
It's so unsatisfying.
It's weird.
It's depressing and we do the Goddamn
same thing.
We've become too good adaptations of
mutate state and that's what was trying
to say earlier with the.
They influences the paradigm,
the template that we're moving towards
these two predicated on the material to
the point where yeah,
it's ludicrous.
Things I think like you joined the
comparison between the neck things and
hearing things in the condition that
that power that we're harnessing all
seems to center around innovation when
we're pursuing material possessions,
when we're pursuing physical items,
we're not talking about like vintage
things like I'm really into handmade
things.
I love a handmade bag or handmade knife.
I love the idea that someone created
something,
crafted something,
but those things are the same.
Like if you buy a knife that some guy
made hammering in a,
you know,
one of those vats of fucking fire and
Bang,
you're dead.
He's doing it the same way.
People have done it for hundreds if not
thousands of years.
There's something fascinating about that
and interesting about that,
but in terms of like progression and
innovation,
it's like you can't compete with these
God damn laptops or phones or any of
these things.
Those things are,
they're getting better and better at
this staggering exponential rate and at
the end of that line,
see this.
If you've,
if you extrapolate,
if you look at it from a distance,
you pull yourself away from culture and
civilization and look down what is this
super being called,
the human race?
What is the super organism doing,
which creating better and better things?
Well,
why is it doing that?
Why is it ignoring the very ocean that
surrounds it?
Why is it sucking all the fish out of
the ocean and shitting all the fucking
dirt and dust up into the air,
but ignoring that while concentrating on
the possession and the innovation of all
these electronic gadgets?
Well,
it's got to be something to do with
that.
It's like a pole and Mckenna used to
call it an attractor that we're being
pulled towards some future attract or
some singularity event.
Some moment that we are creating,
whether we're aware of it or not,
but that part of all of our ridiculous
behavior in terms of our ego and our
drive for success and attention and love
and affection,
all of these different things is really
sort of pushing this innovation further
and further and quicker and quicker and
it's extremely interesting idea what it
feels thinking when you're saying that.
It's like,
oh,
every time that's happening,
the creativity you'll put where all of
these things before the exact same
things exist in this unrealized realm,
will play over,
refer to as the realm of ideas that
there's an idealized form of all things
before they are realized in the material
world.
Like someone designing a knife has to
consciously conceive of the knife before
bringing it into the material world.
That there's this constant need to pull
from this unrealized like whenever I see
babies now,
I wanted to get him.
Where were you?
What was your countries?
That's telling me what it's like to
hopefully still am
friendly with David Lynch,
the film maker,
and he told me that a friend of his over
were outside their kids' nursery and
they had a three year old kid in a six
month year old,
can't don't say years after my six month
old kid and they heard the free route
go.
The six month kid,
I need you to tell me about heaven again
because I'm beginning to forget
David Lynch.
I blew my mind.
Where is consciousness before I forget.
Oh,
as a person,
and Jim,
you can back me up on this.
As a person who has kids,
one of the most bizarre aspects of child
raising is that when you have them in
their babies,
these moments when they're little and
tiny,
you think,
I will never gonna forget this.
This is the most powerful moment of my
life.
This is amazing.
Being around them when they're so little
and their first words,
they're talking to you,
but you fucking forget it.
You forget it all because you know them
as the them.
They are now at six or at eight or at 10
or at 14,
and those incredibly powerful moment you
forget,
but meanwhile you're.
You remember some cut you off in traffic
14 years ago and you're like,
I should have kicked out fucking guys as
I saw him at the red light and I didn't
get out of my car and it haunts me to
this day on a drag him out of his car
and feed him his fucking teeth.
You remember that,
but you won't remember your daughter
being to dancing to some music that's on
television and everybody laughing and
cheering along.
You have to see it.
You have to look at a fucking video that
you saved on your iphone and watch it
and you go,
oh yeah,
that's right.
Oh my God,
what an amazing moment.
Somehow or another almost like dreams,
those ideas are erased from the
accessible memory in some strange way or
many of them are.
So when you hear a three year old st do
a six month,
that is fucking crazy because it makes
you wonder,
is that one of them?
Because that's one of the properties of
DMT by the way in which is the
psychedelic that's created by your own
brain.
One of the major properties of that
dream is how profound the visions are.
Incredibly powerful,
but then they slip through your hands.
They are gone.
They're gone.
Just like a dream.
When you wake up from a dream and you
try to explain it to somebody,
you have a very small window.
Will
you explain that dream
consciousness?
Yeah.
There's powerful moments.
Does eraser?
Yes,
but there's also a powerful,
really good moments that I've had with
each one of my kids and I can literally
at of all the monster.
I said,
I don't remember this.
You still let them in the museum of your
mind.
I have forgotten most,
but there's a handful that I remember.
Well,
I say if it was yesterday,
that was on a deeper spiritual conscious
level where we just locked eyes and it
was a moment and we just knew everything
about each other.
That Mo,
I can't.
Maybe I wanted that moment,
but that's how it felt and I can count
that with each one of my kids.
Where I always go back to going,
wow,
I really know who you really are and I'm
trying to get you back to that.
Does it make sense?
Does I think that we have an accessible
database,
we have a hard drive,
we have a certain amount of space and
that's been proven when it comes to how
many people you can know and keeping
your life.
They say that you could keep about 150
people in your life and you can sort of
remember these people and you can you
hold these people,
but once you go past 1:50 it gets
fucking slippery as shit and you must
experience that because you're
constantly meeting people and people
know who you are and you don't remember
them and after awhile you can go nice to
meet you and they go.
We already met.
We met three years ago.
Oh,
I forgot.
Yeah.
I cannot maintain this many connections.
The same basis drive issue.
It's a literal hard drive issue.
I forget what is the fucking.
I know that it's not bodes laws the size
of planets.
It's A.
I forget the principal,
but the principal is a 100 or whatever
the word is.
It's 150 people and you keep those
hundred 50 people in your head and
that's it.
It correlates to what we were talking
about with chimpanzees and anthropology,
that there is a,
there isn't an ideal size for a
community before it becomes a disease to
know to deal with,
but those things you were talking about,
your children.
There are like a transcendent moment.
Dunbar's number.
That's it.
Cool.
Try and like you're talking about
moments where it didn't matter that your
individual way and that's individual,
be that there's a clear connection that
something.
Parsley is between us and it was.
It was overpowering and beautiful just
for that moment and that keeps me going
in certain moments of time,
even though I'm 15 years later in 20,
I I know know could describe it to me.
I just know that on some level that can
be broken down I'm sure to sort of oxy
toast in and like,
oh,
this is the shoreline was triggered by
that.
There is a sort of a mechanical or
material component to even the most
beautiful experiences of a sunset away,
whatever it is,
but my.
But to return to what you were saying
before of like how we have five or
negative information,
there's a clear evolutionary bias for
like negative information has to be
stored because you know he's not a
career.
Is that line you better.
You know what I mean?
You're fucked.
If it's alliance.
Negative information does have like
priority,
but what were you saying about like sort
of this continued technological
evolution?
What I.
What I think is that there's an
imperative to have a comparable
spiritual evolution revolution and that
can occur is like the mortar.
I meditate and spent time doing that
sort of stuff.
It gives me a more of an awareness of
the kind of phenomenon you're talking
about,
about the positive things and I'm like,
you know about,
oh my God,
I must hold this moment in my heart.
The moment where my dog done now or the
moment I found out my girlfriend was
pregnant.
Don't fucking let this go this.
Go make this part of who you are as a
character and try to prioritize it over
negative things or when someone hurts,
you know,
and,
and I think that one has more
determination over that more or 40 over
that if you have meditation as part of
Your Life,
if you have a spiritual component to it.
And that was when I was a teenager and
noticed that my mates were all the time.
It's like,
you know,
I'd hang out with my mates were smoking
loads to draw.
Then we get in the car,
we go out,
they go to work.
My mate would lucky worked in a car
factory and then he would go and work
doors to insecurity and I fought this
guy.
Never ever is like Justin.
Yeah.
He's never still,
he's never in reflection is always
engaged with some extent,
for as a really lovely guy.
As a matter of fact he was.
But like I,
I became aware then,
but that's myself,
that I was part of my addiction was
these uncontrolled drives always want in
something approval sex that I was unable
to be still.
And being so unlike so many fucking
things like,
you know,
like I'm not Christian,
but it's so many things,
biblical things like,
uh,
you know,
the Kingdom of Heaven is spread upon the
earth,
but man sees it not the Kingdom of
Heaven is within.
Be still and know that I am God,
you know,
like,
sort of like for me,
all that fuzzy fucking rapture,
cloud kingdom bullshit.
You know,
that,
you know,
that's no use to anybody.
But when people are saying to you,
it's in there,
it's in there.
Is there already,
you know,
like there is no,
of course we are also living in a
material world and I'm a material girl.
So because we can't drop the drive to
continue to create these great
achievements as a species.
But a part of it has got to be you learn
how to conduct yourself,
learn how to connect your emotions,
learn how to store positive experiences,
and learn how to let go of negative
ones.
You know,
if that,
if that day originality with people.
Yeah,
we've all got our paths,
everyone.
We've all got our individual attributes
and skills.
Like you said,
if we were on communism,
the island,
you know,
you need people like to people to be
realizing what is their part of the
divine,
what is the little part of you that's
trying to realize itself,
but life's kept fucking knocking you
back in.
The systems kept breaking you down and
you've not got to realize that thing
that you can feel like a tree.
You're trying to grow into your.
That's the.
That's the part of it I think can only
happen as part of a spiritual evolution
and I think you can even.
You can only get the ticket to the
spiritual evolution if you learn to deal
with this fucking Matt stimulating
bullshit that we're jacked up on.
What's what you said,
meditate.
You turn it all off.
It's really hard.
I got turn it all off,
nothing and your mind will have a chance
to grow.
I also think that that's where the
compelling feeling to gravitate towards
that comes from a dissatisfaction with
the material world,
dissatisfaction with this idea of
possessions and that there is some sort
of a weird ebb and flow and a Yin and
Yang to the world and sometimes you have
to see the fucking disastrous effects of
just giving in to material possessions
and the compelling feeling of wanting
attention and nonsense and just
gathering up items and living in the
biggest house.
You have to almost feel the emptiness of
that to gravitate towards a spiritual
approach and I think that's one of the
reasons why those things are there.
It's almost like people do horrible
things.
Like sometimes I feel like horrible
things when they're manifested by the
human race.
They sort of,
they,
they can give birth to a lot of positive
reactions because people don't ever want
to be like that and they see that and
they go,
well,
this is definitely not the way to go
because we're kind of all going through
it together.
One of the things about the human mind
and the human experience like being a
conscious human is we assume that we're
this static thing.
Meanwhile we're,
we're very well aware that evolution
exists all throughout the natural world
and we're also aware,
well aware that we've only really been
this thing for like what a half,
a million quarter of a million years.
It's not been that long that you could
go back and find a,
an ancient human and they look like you
could put it in your clothes and put it
in a movie theater and we wouldn't freak
out.
It's not that long.
It's a short amount of time.
So if you think about the fact that we
know that these animals and these,
these things are constantly evolving and
changing and adapting all around us,
why would we assume that we're in some
sort of a static state?
Why?
I think that our own gravitation towards
material possessions in our own use of
this new form of interacting with each
other through social media and the
Internet and and movies and all those
things are new.
We have to understand that mass media is
fucking knew as shit.
All of it.
Newspapers are new as fuck everything.
Everything's a couple hundred years old.
The oldest shit is a couple hundred
years old,
photographs,
couple hundred years old.
We're dealing with really,
really,
really new influences on the mind and
the mind is developing and expanding and
reacting to all these new things and
sometimes it reacts in a very negative
way like it gravitates towards the
Kardashians and it goes towards fucking
possessions and it wants the shiniest
new thing to show everybody that you've
arrived and it's.
It's a part of a cog in unconscious cog
in this machine that's just producing
new items and then sometimes there's a
guy like you who sees that and goes,
there is no soul to that.
I'm going to jump in the fucking lake
near these royals house and I'm going to
experience what it's like to freeze my
dick off and I'm going to carve a new
path and I'm going to separate and I'm
going to try domesticity and I'm going
to try abstinence and I'm going to try
to find some sort of a new way of
addressing my dissatisfaction with the
current state of the world that I find
myself in that that was fucking good.
Rent.
I needed a date.
It was.
I mean
it does that,
but there's a part of that and all of
us.
We're all just going,
this ain't it?
Maybe this is.
It does it in it.
Maybe it's yoga,
maybe it's scientology.
Maybe it's being a moonie.
Maybe it's this.
Maybe it's that.
Maybe it's maybe this fucking chick is
holding me back.
I need a goddamn divorce,
but the fuck away from me.
I know I'm going to wear a captain's
outfit now.
Find some chick lives by the beach.
Go to the captain's outfit.
We wanted to live out of my car and
travel around the world.
I'm going to put a bed in the back seat
and you know,
it's like this fax faction which has
been happening forever.
Just go right through there.
Yeah,
right through that door for
that.
Can I do it time?
I was trying to be a man.
I mean for me to be in another room.
They ain't got used lots of voices.
We drank three waters.
I've drank two in one and I got to Piss
like a horse and I can hold this shit in
for another day
so it takes a strong bladder to do a
podcast.
Jim,
by the way,
I should just say what we're doing this.
One of the reasons why I really got into
on a podcast,
there's a bunch of them,
a opie and anthony were a big one,
but you're fucking show was a big one
man.
When I did your show and we did it at
that joke place,
that joke place on Ventura Boulevard
member.
You were in La and you were in town and
I had done your show like calling in
before,
but I'd never like.
We've never done together.
I was like,
this is so fucking fun.
Just hanging.
Well,
what I loved about that one too is you.
It what that thing allowed me to do is
believe,
believing,
not thought provoking.
Let other people to one that to me,
one of the greatest moments ever was you
called in and we wrote,
we were all sitting there and I fuck
you.
Went into this whole thing of these are
the Times of truth and this and that and
I think you spoke for 45 minutes
straight and I just kept looking.
Everyone going,
don't just let them go.
This is,
this is,
this is fascinating.
Let him go,
where else can you have this?
And one of my guys made like this whole
pink floyd music and he put it on the
air.
I said,
you've got to get that in the Internet
and I think I remember calling your
telling you go and show this is.
That was the most fascinating thing ever
heard in my life.
So I thought I was going to die,
but it doesn't.
I'm sure you are,
but you never were allowed to even think
like that on radio.
And one of the things you said too,
it's my favorite part was uh,
and again I end up fear in it because I
didn't want people thinking it was our
opening song,
which just explained,
it was just four of us.
We came out to,
uh,
get musicians that you came and you're
like,
drill.
That is the,
that is the greatest theme song I've
ever heard in my life.
And I was like,
really?
Yeah.
What was you,
what was me and the guys?
And we were just really just talking and
we've ripped it.
And I said,
don't even don't even change it.
Let's just do that.
It was perfect.
It was real.
Yes.
And then I knew I,
I knew when I heard you,
you,
you have,
you need to be in this world.
It's great to.
It's,
it's great to have you in this world.
It's refreshing.
It's thought provoking.
It's powerful.
It's.
I love it,
man.
I'm very,
very.
I love it.
Yeah.
Well,
I love it too,
man.
It's a unique time that we can,
we can have something like this.
And when I was on your show,
I was like,
man,
I need to get one of these satellite
radio shows.
These are the shit I didn't know that
there was going to be an Internet
version of that where you don't have any
bosses and it reaches even more people.
It doesn't make any sense at all.
Who's somehow or another,
a path has been carved through the
information highways that people have
never been on before.
It's only like 10 years old.
And through that path you reach
everybody and it's free.
Like it's,
it violates all the ideas of capitalism.
You don't have to pay for it.
It's massively successful and there's a
500,000 of them and it lives forever,
forever,
forever.
So people can constantly discover a.
Did you allegedly.
Allegedly.
I mean,
I'm.
What I'm saying is like,
we might not make it an asteroid hits
whatever until that happens,
is be nice to know that someone that's
never even heard of you.
Oh yeah.
In 20 years down the road they're going,
you need to listen to this conversation.
You know,
Russell brand was in there and this day
did he listened to that 20 years from
now they're going,
you know,
that makes.
That makes a lot of sense.
That's pretty awesome.
This is the great part of social media.
Well,
the grapevine,
it's also that it's all free and that
they're all available.
You can get 800 plus episodes of this
thing anytime you want it and when
things are free,
you can be more honest and more
passionate about what you put out there
because no one's paying you to say,
well,
did you ever get any pressure when you
were doing the satellite show that ever?
Did anybody ever come to you and go
ahead,
Jim,
you know,
we're,
we listen to that show and you guys are.
You got to tone it down.
Never.
That's amazing.
Never say never.
Never,
never,
never.
Because opie and Anthony got suspended a
couple of times.
Even from satellite radio.
They were getting A.
First of all,
they were getting a lot of commercial
money.
Yup.
That's certainly where they rubbed the
wrong side of the madness.
You know,
it was all over Fox News.
Look,
you go to,
well,
they were kind of compromised in some
sort of a weird way whether they want it
to be or not because they were making a
fuck load of money and as soon as a
company is paying you x amount of money
every year and they get upset about
something or they feel it,
feel like the Rav advertising revenue is
going to dry up because you guys said
something crazy like,
you remember when they had that homeless
guy on who said some crazy shit about
Condoleezza Rice?
No.
Yeah,
they,
they got suspended for like a year or
like a month or something like that.
They had,
uh,
some might be a week.
I'm making up numbers.
They um,
had some homeless guy on it came on and
said he wanted a rape Condoleeza Rice or
something and they,
you know,
like what the fuck.
And they just had some crazy guy off the
street and he talked to all kinds of
crazy nonsense and he left and you know,
it's all alive.
So it's nothing you could do about it.
This guy in the air,
I mean,
what the fuck are they going to do it
lp?
Didn't say it.
Anthony didn't say Norton didn't say it,
but because it was on their show,
they pulled the show and it was probably
because of political pressure or pull up
pressure from the Bush administration.
This is also coincidentally during the
time where,
I mean Howard Stern,
it was just after the time of Howard
stern getting sued over and over again
by the government.
Remember they would.
They would give these massive lawsuits
and that drove him to satellite radio.
Right,
and even in satellite radio they weren't
safe,
so even in satellite radio he moved to
satellite radio.
He moved to Sirius Xm at the time,
I think it was before the merge of
Sirius Xm or maybe right afterwards,
but either way they.
They weren't free.
Even under the banner of this free thing
on satellite radio.
The political machine still had
influence.
Yeah.
We'd never.
We never were told,
don't say this amazing.
Don't do that.
Because you had some wild fucking shows
they would do.
They would
go,
hey,
lisinopril ratings time.
It looks good.
If you guys were to come up with a
biggie kind of entertaining show that
would like that we can get out there.
And the uh,
did you get to choose guests?
Um,
yeah.
They want to get.
They weren't running to us.
Trust me.
You get to veto anybody usually I
couldn't tell you who it was.
A million guys suck.
I don't know anything about this guy.
I want to talk to them.
What am I getting out of that?
So they bring the politician.
I'm just going to be a dick.
Yeah.
See,
that's a beautiful thing about the time
that you were involved in it too because
you were involved in it.
Back when I was on fear factor because
the stunt guys fucking loved your show
man.
There was a,
I had to do this thing where I got in
the truck.
We had to drive to some location,
was hanging out with the stunt guys and
they were playing your show when it was
on raw dog and they loved it and they
were like,
dude,
brewers show is the fucking best.
And it was really wild and raw and I was
like,
you maybe couldn't even do that today.
Well those are my best friends growing
up and my best friends was Jimmy Shaka
who was deep and we would have these
conversations for hours.
And it really bothered me that there was
no outlet for this anywhere.
You had to be a freak or widow,
a hippie or or whatever.
And then I had another best friend on
there who works for Fedex.
He was,
he had the blue collar.
He stuck in that blue collar
neighborhood.
Little Ray says,
but he won't really just two years and
and the nucleus.
And then you had core Yeley who's just,
he'll say whatever he was,
he'll,
he'll just go and say whatever and do
whatever.
So it was great to have all these
different views,
honest views.
And if some days we just fit in.
The big rule was no news,
no pop culture.
If you bring pop culture on the show,
your route with were antipop culture.
You're out,
you're fired.
Get that name,
your band forever.
Less beautiful.
And a lot of ways.
But it was saying too,
it's just as a hang.
I was trying to get it back to tribal is
whatever.
At the end of the day isn't some of the
best times you have conversations like
these or when you're with the people you
trust the most.
That could be the kid you grew up with.
It could be.
Can Be anyone,
a family member,
someone you just met and you're just
hanging out at the end of the night.
You don't care if this one's dylan or
that window.
You're just hanging out.
There's a fire,
you're talking.
At the end of the day,
it's all the same shit.
What's out there?
Who really knows?
What's this?
Who really fucking knows?
Let's talk about and try to figure out
for three hours and what we get out of
it.
Poor.
Really fucking know it's time for bed,
but kids get now you have six hours,
but if feel great that you're all doing
it together.
You trust each other.
I'm not.
Am I crazy for saying this?
I might be.
He'll tell me,
dude,
you fucking crazy.
Why would you say that's stupid?
That's stupid.
Why is that stupid and just that that
was pretty with each other and
they make more sense that way.
If I trust you and your instincts in
your mind that I'll tell you something
that I believe in you,
you refused it and they'll go,
oh,
okay.
I have to consider his point of view
because if I trust your point of view
and your point of view differs from
mine,
well how did he come to this conclusion
and why is it so different than my own?
And by absorbing a bunch of different
points of view like that,
it gives you a much more nuanced
perspective of this existence and you
have to be open.
I'm not out to win the conversation on
just we're just here to learn from it
more.
That's important.
People have to be open with that and I
think we're.
We've all been guilty of not being open
to that before wanting to be right,
but it's important to not just embrace
being wrong,
but try to understand why you were
wrong.
Trying to understand like what it was
and not be connected in some weird ego
way to your ideas.
It's hard to get just a joe fuck yeah,
but it's like all those other things
that we're talking about.
I mean like you saying that you have
this,
this gravitation towards a expelling all
of these ridiculous notions that
everybody is just sort of accepted as
fact and truth and trying to connect
with a much more spiritual as well.
That means you've got to think about and
it's got to be a conscious thing and the
same thing with not holding onto your
ideas and not being married to them and
not not being invested in being correct
or incorrect,
but just sort of accepting them as just
ideas and be able to go,
yeah,
I think you're right.
Why was I thinking that?
And that's hard for people to do.
I know this is stupid,
but I saw a statement was in someone
went and it was a tourist spot,
but I pass the tourist spot and went in
the house
and there was a statement in there and I
know it just.
It's simple,
but it just blew my mind.
It said one person could change the
whole world for a better as long as they
don't give a damn who gets that credit
and that and I,
and I thought like,
if you really don't,
if you just want to sit back,
you just want to see things better and
you really can change for the better,
but you don't have to worry about going,
you know,
so and so said that or someone so set
that up was so and so did that because
now you're doing it for different
reasons.
Yeah.
I never had that before.
I'd never heard that before until like
yesterday I saw like I saw that quote
intimate.
It can.
That's a problem that I continually have
to almost ideas.
And that's,
I think part of what's excellent about
this medium and particularly the way
it's been executed by you look,
is that it's,
it's discourse,
you know,
let these kind of things.
Not really,
you know,
like you said,
the fast moving fast cut sound bite tv,
just bombarding with an artillery of
mostly erroneous information.
You don't get to people here.
People our,
after our talk in examining this
guarding as you said,
who really knows and returning to that
point,
it's sort of,
it's sort of encouraging because I've
had like,
you know,
like as I like,
I've always felt like an I don't like
agree with like a bill o'reilly
or Sean Hannity or those guys.
I've always kind fall apart.
I think they were right if I hung out
with.
There's something about Bill O'Reilly
Camacho carve.
Oh,
come on.
Like I think,
I think he was kind of okay.
I think you would joke around with them
and you guys probably start laughing
about some things and that's kind of a
reassuring thing,
isn't it?
And to not be kind of like once you get
a Ta,
like I think that's what's kind of ugly
about both liberalism and neoliberalism
is you can see it as people just forcing
their idea and they've lost touch with.
And I do it all the fucking time.
Yeah.
Let's start with what is it that we're
genuinely here for.
And that thing you said of like you can
change the world if you know no one.
Like if you're willing to do,
if no one knowing about it,
that's like,
ah,
the,
the pangs I feel in my gut shows me how
much my ego is still involved in the
shit I do.
Discourse.
I just saw it.
I didn't say it,
but the lack of discourse,
like what we were talking about being
one of the more important things about
podcasts or one of the best things about
podcasts.
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm really hoping that that's the trend
of the future,
that people understand that there's,
this might not be a right way or a wrong
way to do a lot of these things and that
your point of view,
whether you strongly believe it or not
might not really work for the way I see
the world.
It doesn't mean that your right or I'm
wrong or it doesn't.
It doesn't.
I mean there's some certain truths like,
Hey,
don't rape people.
don't murder people.
Those things are obvious,
but there's some other things that
aren't obvious.
You know,
there's other things.
Rob,
not obvious,
like maybe you shouldn't hurt people's
feelings.
Something.
Maybe you should them because what
they're doing is preposterous and in
hurting their feelings,
you actually elevate all of us to
realize the humor in their folly and I'm
a big fan of folly.
I enjoy human folly.
It's one of the things I enjoy most
about humans.
I'm the quickest to make fun of my own
self,
so if I can't make fun of them,
what kind of a fucking goofy ass world
that we run and we run into some super
sensitive world where everyone's a
perfect snowflake and we can't shit on
them.
Like nonsense.
You need humility.
Humility is also.
Humor is really important to unpackage
things like because there was a lot of
things that are going on right now in
this world that are a little fucking
weird and one of the reasons why they're
weird is because humor hasn't had a
chance to dissect them.
Wow.
I think that A.
Please talking about comedy and he said
that people talk about like the people
are very and humor because they know
it's powerful and they often use the
idea that tell,
don't talk,
don't,
don't joke around.
This is serious.
Supposed to joke around about things
serious and he they have mistaken
seriousness for solemnity,
you know,
there's no reason they want to be all
solid about stuff because they know it
prevents people that have got that
comedic switchblade from getting into
the argument.
We can exactly taking that seriously.
I'm not playing by those rules and
they've also taken away your special
power special power habit.
This special power.
Both of you guys have it like they don't
have it,
so if you come in and you deflate their
argument with a quick switchblade,
oh,
a piece of shit while you're joking
around
about something really important,
maybe your white privilege is showing.
Maybe you should consider the fact that
your humor is offensive to people and
what you're doing.
It's bullshit and it's not helping.
It's very regressive.
Trying to
stitch it into political.
One of the real problems with the left
and especially the regressive left and
the PR people that think that they're
going to change things,
they're fucking unbelievably mean when
they're mocking the right.
Like you're talking about compassion,
like I've seen some of the most,
the least compassion,
meanest,
angriest shit come out of people that
consider themselves to be liberal and
progressive and their ideas to close
down discourse where they're going to do
is going to shit on you and insult you
and then gang up and some sort of a
weird bully pulpit to attack all the
people that don't agree with them.
We're not going involved in politics in
my country doing that thing.
The truth,
the most number of book as well called
Revolution.
And in that book I talked about it.
It was basically a book those meant to
be for younger people and it was like,
this is my perspective on why I don't
believe in this stuff and why I believe
in this.
And it was really,
you know,
it was relatively simple.
And again,
I'm like a self taught person.
So it's not a book by fucking academic,
right?
The worst vitriol and their worst
condemnation came from the kind of
newspapers and liberal organizations
that would think would be supportive of
such.
Like it's good that he's guy from the
world of popular entertainment who's not
a classically educated.
It's trying to do that.
No,
they came in,
they came in like get the fuck out of
our
territory.
Who Do you think
more than any kind of like a sort of
right wing organization that they almost
see it has gone wrong.
Jolly good.
Yeah.
I was really like.
I was very.
Some people that I thought might be
allies,
organizations I thought might be
encouraging.
We're very condemnatory.
Well,
you going to realize the what is the
mechanism that they're distributing this
information with?
You know what they're doing there.
They're writing their own stories.
They're promoting their own blogs.
They're doing their own radio shows and
in fact feeding their own ego like we
were talking about before,
that green monster of envy that sees
this fucking guy with beautiful bone
structure and the beautiful accent.
Now I'm philosophizing this piece of
shit he had.
He had the wherewithal and the power to
go on a sexual rampage.
Chose to back off of it and realize like
all these fucking goddamn things he's
got going for him.
He's a fucking movie star.
Fuck this guy.
I'm telling him I'm tearing them down,
honey,
and he's sitting there with his pot
belly fucking taken his antidepressants
and tap tapping away mean shit on the
keyboard hoping and hoping that these
mean words hit your mind and they enter
into your consciousness and he can
affect you in some sort of a horrible
way.
Oh God.
The lack of extreme lack of compassion
from some people on the left and the
green light to attack this fact that,
oh,
here's this guy and I don't agree with
him and I think that what he's doing is
sexist and it's massage and nearest dick
and it's enabling and let's get them.
Well,
you got to fucking target right on his
back attack.
Oh,
he's doing press.
well,
I'm going to be involved in this press.
I don't know.
Throw my hat into the ring as the
arbiter of intelligent ideas to dismay
or dismantle rather all these fucking
stupid thoughts at this shit head with
his perfect bone structure and men bonds
pumping out.
Fuck him.
Professional wrestling,
you know,
professional wrestling.
Well,
people,
man,
people jockeying for their own little
fucking shining moment in the darkness.
Pizza Front.
See,
I go conspiracy pizza front,
right?
Here's what our magazines and bend.
So yours.
Is it conspiracy?
It's just a thought.
Why does it have to be cold conspiracy?
I think the word conspiracy is a
conspiracy
conspiracy best at this through the
looking glass.
Now conspiracy in itself is a
conspiracy.
Him.
He's fucking shut it all down.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean there's definitely some real
conspiracies,
but uh,
I think that there's just an unnatural
emphasis of our natural inclination to
Shit on people that are doing better
than you are.
Shit on people that have something good
going on.
And also when you're writing a story
about something w,
how much fun is it running a story
that's positive and how much more
satisfying is it to unhappy people to
write a negative review about something
so much more exciting?
It's much more fun.
I've seen people distort people's ideas
and really horrific ways because that's
the old way because the old way you
could write a blog about something or an
article in a magazine or whatever about
someone and distort it in horrible ways
and they really didn't have any
recourse,
but that old way doesn't really work
anymore because it's direct access
because of media like this.
Sure.
So I'm thinking that I would like to
start a podcast.
I'm thinking you should definitely have
never done a podcast in my games.
They went in my country.
Oh my gosh.
You can do it anywhere you go.
Do whatever you want.
Yeah,
you can bring them whenever you want.
I might have done them in Australia.
I've done them all over the world.
You,
you do it anywhere you want.
All you have to have a phone.
You do it into your iphone.
Exactly.
I just talk on my phone.
I like it.
You dumping that.
You don't have to edit.
You know it's on your phone,
your podcasts on your phone,
dude.
Your design,
your desire.
You are.
And not only that,
you don't even have to have a guest you
want,
but you don't.
You could have a guest on if you want,
but like bill burrs,
one of the best podcasts in the world,
and Bill Burgess rants,
unbelievable.
He rants for like,
he'll just sit down for a fucking hour
and a half and just go off about this
and that.
And it's a stream of consciousness.
So it goes from football to his wife or
his fucking dog and baking and his
internet socks and he's tired of
construction workers and his driveway is
a piece of shit and he just,
he'll go on and on and on.
And you can do that too.
What main things you've learned from
doing this?
What are the main things you think?
Right?
This is how you do a podcast.
One of the things that the rules,
the structures that you have learned,
man,
that's,
there's almost.
I've learned so much.
I've learned how other people perceive
me.
I've learned how I perceive other
people.
I've learned what my,
maybe my own problems and perception
are.
I've,
uh,
I've sort of tried to examine as many
things as possible.
It's a master course in human
interaction for me.
That's what I've thought of it.
I mean I've had 800 plus podcasts where
I'm interacting with all sorts of
different people.
So it's um,
it's a fascinating way to understand how
people think and to just chunk data,
just chunk data about how people react
and talk and communicate.
How has it evolved from your original
vision of doing a hook costing to how it
is now?
If you become more free with it?
Less formulated?
Well,
I don't think it was ever formulated,
but I've been better at it.
I'm just better at it.
But the,
when the podcast started out,
it was just,
I just wanted to figure out a way to do
something like something free where
you're just doing it with a camera or
you're responding to twitter questions
or to trying to out.
My thought was I've done a bunch of
radio shows everywhere I go everywhere I
go and promote a comedy gig.
I do a morning show.
I had a great time.
Gosh,
I would love to do one of those,
but that was so much fun.
I would love a radio show,
but I don't want a boss and that was
trying to figure out how the fuck can I
do this?
And then doing Jim's show and doing the
opiod,
Anthony Show opiod,
not it was the greatest.
It was the greatest because when they
were together,
their show was a hang on.
If I could call Jim and I'd go,
Hey,
uh,
I'm doing opie and Anthony tomorrow
morning.
He's like,
fuck,
I'm doing it too.
Like,
oh,
it's going to be so much fun.
And we would see each other and get a
Bagel in the morning and high five and
go up there and just laugh.
Right.
And you're able to do your own thing.
No one's trying to out,
you know,
it.
It was.
That place taught me everything.
I was hoping it was a hanging.
That was the original Shang.
I'd never heard anything like that.
Yeah,
it was the only radio show that was a
real hang where you go in there and
everyone's just hanging out.
And then Jim started doing his show,
which is very similar when I could get
to you,
you,
your show was a hang too.
It was a hand because I wanted that
model.
I loved going into Opie and Anthony and
just sitting down and they're like,
what's up night?
You didn't have to be on.
Yeah,
they didn't.
Like if you did bits come in and do a
bit,
a bit.
Don't do a bit.
Just talk.
Yeah.
We want to know that that goes probably
what you went through to get where you
can say Russell authenticity about
being,
trying to be in normal and being who you
are.
Yeah.
No imposing.
Like come in and write up in five
seconds.
We got lucky with all of those things
like having a boss and having structure
and having that commercial interests
constantly and you're an intelligent
person and people like listening to the
real you and you don't get that
opportunity a whole lot.
They gave you that opportunity like,
Whoa,
this is a whole different.
I never knew this existed from this
person.
I don't like this person's calm.
I'm sure people hate my book.
And I thought,
but I like what he's like when he talks
real,
so that opens up,
it opens up the opportunity for all of
that.
It was,
it was going to say it was like a
revolution.
It was pretty.
It was pretty intense and I can see what
you mean.
That that was sort of pop the transition
and how it actually works as well.
Like someone that someone that was so
pi.
He is absolutely the original.
He's absolutely,
he's the first.
He's the most important guy in the
history of radio because he was the
first guy that got arrested or a find
rather he got in some serious legal
problems because of the things that he
was saying on the air and kept doing it.
And he was the original guy,
just be blatantly honest.
And he was the first real reality show.
He'd call his wife,
call.
Oh the guys working on the light.
Let me talk to him.
Let me talk to the.
He said like he's getting took,
I want to talk to.
And he did all this on regular radio,
right when no one was doing that and
everybody was playing music.
So they were all.
They would have like these little things
they would do and then they would play a
song and he had to do that in the
beginning.
Songs,
he would make his humor in between the
songs but eventually was like,
fuck these songs,
I'm just gonna I'm just going to be me
and have a good time and talk shit.
And he figured out how to do it.
He was more rigid and structured.
Whereas opie and Anthony,
when they would have guests on,
like,
like brewer and I would be on maybe
burwood beyond or some other people
would beyond and we'd all beyond
together and would just go in there and
we'd hang out and it was literally like,
the time would fly so fast.
We.
It wasn't a matter of not having enough
content.
It was like too much content,
not enough time.
And Howard didn't have that.
It was almost like they wouldn't.
Howard didn't have that opportunity at
the time or he just came out in a
different way.
And then once he went to the Internet,
I think that blew up to another hole at
blew him up to and everyone said,
hi,
you know,
where's he now?
I think he's 10 times,
hundred times bigger and more powerful.
And it became a.
He evolved in terms of content or do you
mean every for me,
everything,
everything.
Conversation thought.
Well,
as soon as things get on the Internet,
then they can spread freely.
So the merit of the conversation.
What's interesting about the
conversation?
Then it just gets passed around and as
soon as things just get passed around
like that,
then someone calls him,
Oh my God,
you got to hear Jim Brewer who was on
Howard Stern.
Holy Shit.
Is it funny?
If you heard it,
you got link and they send you a link.
And Bam.
And the beautiful thing about podcasts
is someone can tell me,
dude,
Russell's got a podcast.
You've got to check it out.
Oh,
let me check it out.
And then you go on your itunes to nap
and you go run.
There is Bam.
And then you're playing it like in
seconds you're in your car and you're
playing it and it's free.
And now if I just discovered you,
I'm going to go.
I want to hear more.
I want to hear.
Oh you got to listen to like one of his
first ones where he wasn't even ready.
He know what he was doing.
You gotta listen where it went from here
to here.
Yeah.
Once they're in,
they're in.
They love you.
They know you.
They feel like they're all exposed will
if you add that you liked were hard or
like,
you know,
like see,
because you've not got bosses or
anything.
Was there ever times you are going to.
We should never read that guy on that
was a mistake.
A couple minor ones.
Nothing serious.
Just weird conversations where you just
kinda learn better about how to handle
those moments.
It's,
it's a,
it's almost like you're learning on the
job,
right?
It's like I never did a radio show
before.
I never spoke open as a form of
entertainment.
Not Arrogant.
Not just to think that you should be
able to speak.
I mean,
of course everyone should be able to
speak,
but the fact that you think that your
words are so interesting that other
people are gonna listen to them and
they're going to,
instead of talking to themselves,
they can just listen to your talking.
Why the fuck would they do that?
They're not even there.
You know,
like it's not like someone's right in
front of you and you're talking to me
trying to be polite so you'll let them
talk.
No,
you're,
you're downloading their shit so you can
listen to them talk and then you're not
gonna talk while they're talking.
Like what?
This is madness,
right?
So in learning how to broad broadcast in
air quotes,
learning how to do that,
you kind of learning by,
by feedback and also by listening
yourself and listening to other people's
podcasts,
you'll see other things that great on
you about what other people do.
Like talking over people.
That's a big one.
We all do it,
which we all shouldn't,
but we all have an idea that we want to
get out and we don't know when to do it
and it's hard to figure out because
we're all free ball and when to jump in
and when not to.
Also,
some people don't listen to the things
that other people say.
They just wait for their turn to talk.
That is a real issue.
That's a giant issue because then you
ask them about what you just said and
they're like,
I wasn't listening.
Like how can you not be listening when
we're talking like this is okay.
They will.
Then now we're not really having a
conversation.
We're just exchanging rants,
you know,
and I'm waiting for you to get your
completely nonsequitor rant in and then
you're going to impress people with your
quotes and home,
which you know about this guy or that
guy.
And that's a real common thing is like
using it as an ego springboard instead
of looking at it in the podcast is
really essentially a piece of art in a
grandiose term,
but you're creating something and you
want to create it.
The best way you can and you could fuck
it up by being loud and stupid and
saying a bunch of dumb shit that doesn't
feel good to anybody here.
Or You could say some cool shit that
when they listen to this podcast,
after it's over,
they go,
fuck at Russell brand,
said something that's going to change
the way I look at the rest of my fucking
life and that's,
that's possible.
And that's one of the bases entirely.
Like do you think then this is entirely
authentic self that you don't like?
Stuff that you withhold when you're in
this situation?
Because I've come from more conventional
media and information about loved ones.
That's it.
I don't,
I don't know anything.
I don't want to hurt any.
I don't want anybody of anybody else's
feelings get hurt or you know,
things along those lines.
But I've made those mistakes smart just
because it's funny.
It's a funny team there.
Yeah.
It's not their choice,
you know,
so you have to,
you have to withhold certain things and
you know,
some people just want to be private
people.
They don't want to have any part of your
fucking parade.
You weirdo out there talking to the
world everyday.
Have you had any.
Have you had any negative consequences
as a result of it?
Because you have to work in other
industries and all of that.
It's only positive.
I don't give a fuck,
so it doesn't really matter.
If you have fuck you money,
you don't say fuck you,
you're wasting fuck you money.
So if I have some real thoughts and I
don't express them because I'm worried
about job opportunities like I'm already
in prison,
whether I like it or not.
If there's something important that I
have to say and then the jobs that you
do get or the employment opportunities
that you do get,
they'll be looking for your authentic
self and let's say it's some like the
same sort of situation with some crazy
woman likes to take some guy and change
them all.
He's a fixer upper like they're not.
They're not going to grab you and go,
this Russell brand's talking a lot of
crazy revolution.
Once we get them in the network,
I'm in a nice suit.
He's gonna.
He's gonna be the best talk show host
ever.
He's the future Jimmy Fallon.
And at the end of the day,
yes.
If it comes to entertainment,
your number.
So does he matter what you say?
They believe it or not.
Believe it and you get these people.
Don't.
Doesn't matter.
I think we should put him in this movie
because he's worth this much and think
of will make this much this many people
automatically buy tickets because his
following is interview.
You almost start controlling your own
destiny that happened as a result.
Things happen to you.
Awful.
I don't.
Well what do you mean not having someone
gone?
Why don't we put fucking Joe Rogan in
this action movie?
You got fucking massive,
but I don't.
I don't.
I'm not interested in doing anything.
I'm interested in doing less things.
I'm not interested in anything new.
I don't want to do any movies.
I like doing stuff that has nothing to
do with work.
Like I like doing yoga and I like doing
archery.
I like writing comedy.
I like performing standup.
I liked to on podcasts I like,
I like just doing stuff.
I don't want to do someone else's stuff,
you know,
some movie came along and it was really
interesting and for whatever reason it
was a short amount of time.
I would have to work,
I would consider it,
but I've passed on a lot of stuff.
I just don't have any interest in it.
He's taking control of your life through
this.
Yeah.
Well I've been doing what I actually
want to do instead of when you know,
and Jim and I were in a pilot for the
very first TV show that I did in 1993
and we've been friends for longer before
that,
way long before that.
But you,
you come here and you think I've now I'm
going to do this project.
Oh boy.
I'm in.
I'm on a TV show and you and then you
get on the TV,
show you up.
You know what?
I don't even like this that much.
I liked doing.
Stand up.
Why am I doing this?
You're doing this because they keep
coming to you like,
Hey,
we've got a game show and they're gonna
eat animal dicks and you're going to
shoot them out of a rocket.
What do you know?
Like,
I'm in,
it's on TV.
I'm in.
That's what I'm here for,
and the money is real fucking good.
You do it after a while and you go,
hey,
you know what?
That's not what I enjoy doing.
What do I actually enjoy doing?
Well,
I'm just trying to do the things I enjoy
doing.
What I enjoy doing.
I like doing podcasts.
I like doing standup.
I like and doing all those
extracurricular things that I do,
the things that I do that are just
interested in life and then I don't want
to differentiate between interests that
I do for financial gain or interest to
it that I do for mental exercises or for
spiritual growth or whatever.
I just want to do things that I enjoy
doing.
That's really important,
isn't it?
You guys sound fair enough and so many
people don't have that kind of freedom
creatively on any level.
The freedom of it.
I just want the that should be part of
more people's experience of life.
I'm happy doing this.
It makes me like.
It's really beautiful to hear that,
that what you're led by his joy because
that is another Joseph Campbell thing.
Follow your bliss.
Find the thing that you're connected to
and follow it,
and when I think of how many times in my
life I've got,
I've lived out other people's ideas as
you say,
like,
Oh,
right now this is.
Hold on a minute.
This is what I'm.
This is what I'm supposed to do.
Like again,
like Bill Hicks says,
they just look at my money.
This has to be real to be real because
you're bombarded with it and then you
realize,
oh my God,
so if you are lucky enough to get to a
position where you can just do things
that you enjoy,
but how do you.
Do you think that idea that you've
applied to your own creative lives can
be applied?
If you're fucking living a normal life
and you're trapped in a job that you
don't fucking like,
how do you think you'd get out of that
situation?
It's like everything else,
it takes small baby steps to move out,
you know,
you've got to move towards that
direction.
You have to have an absolute game plan
and you have to have an actual thing
that you enjoy doing.
Like say if you're some guy that's
trapped in some job but you know,
to bring up something we talked about
before,
what you enjoy making homemade knives
and you think you're like,
you know,
I would love to just be able to make
arts and crafts to be able to create
something that people bond,
maybe pottery or something along those
lines that really feel like spiritually
and creatively satisfying to me.
To be able to express myself in it,
an art form that to do that for a living
would be amazing.
And there's a lot of people that start
off in regular jobs and they figure out
a way to get to that place and it's not
easy and people will fucking bitch and
Moan at you and tell you how not easy it
is.
And Yeah,
you're saying it's making it seem like
it's easy.
It's not easy.
A lot of us have problems and we got
mortgages and children and I need a
healthcare packaging.
Everybody has resistance.
There's always resistance to anything
that you're trying to achieve in life
and everybody's set up might be
different.
Everybody's needs and requirements might
be different.
They're all different,
but if you find whatever the fuck it is
that you can do,
I guarantee you,
you have some time in your day that you
can dedicate towards making that a
reality.
It's a matter of making that time a
priority to try to change your current
state of existence.
How do you do it?
I don't know.
I don't know what your existence is and
I can't tell you anyway because what the
way I do things and the way you do
things is fucking totally different.
Everyone's going to do things different.
I'm a kamikaze person.
I'm like,
let's fucking cut ties,
Polish,
shoot,
let's go.
I'm like,
let's get outta here.
Let's quit.
You know?
Um,
but I've always like that.
I've always been the burn the fucking
house down.
You got to make another one.
That's,
that's my,
my thought has been just abandoned ship.
Let's get Outta here and find the
fucking new thing,
but you can't do that when you have a
wife and children and now luckily for me
when I was young and taking crazy
chances and moving towards a career and
doing something I actually wanted to do,
I didn't have anybody else that I had
that counted on me.
Once you do,
it becomes much more difficult but not
insurmountable.
It didn't completely dependent upon what
it is you're trying to achieve.
I like that we can start.
Good.
Well going to say like,
you know,
sort of
how do you bridge.
You aren't going to,
like I said,
that thing to Tom Cruise,
that time of being born with that drive,
being born with that knowledge of I'm
going to do this because I identify with
that crash and burn thing and it's been
problematic in my life with
relationships and stuff.
I've got a survival instinct in me and
it's like,
this is fucking mad.
I'm out.
Yeah,
but that's good.
How many people fucking stay and get
tortured
sophie when that hard tech comes finally
aren't going away from this con.
Well,
I hope your head,
but if see my fingers,
I would like more people in the world.
Like it will be like Jesus for more
people to have that opportunity.
Like it makes me sad so that people will
be listening to this thinking I fucking
won.
Now I want to make my fucking art and
craft knives.
I wanted it like that.
If you,
if you've not got place for that in your
life,
then you will,
like you were saying when you were in
prison,
you have your fucking fucked anyway and
let you know and there are certain
systemic changes that could be bought
back that would mean that more people
would have that opportunity.
That's the other thing that makes me
sad.
Systemic changes.
Well,
I mean he's,
he's.
But if we didn't have a culture that was
entirely dominated by one economic idea,
that more people would be able to sit
around making art and crafts,
not the finger of the things that keep
coming up again and again.
This conversation,
people should live in small tribes.
I mean,
right?
So why the fuck are we not trying to do
that shit now?
Why are we not going to like,
you know why we don't go in,
right?
Let's try another word for tribes.
Soviet and people did ever go
terribly,
terribly wrong,
but what I'm saying,
they start doing these kind of ideas.
I mean,
look,
now I'd be like,
I wonder if that's that,
you know,
that's the template.
What's the next level of this is like,
right,
but let's try and work on that.
Then they try and bring some of these
ideas like you have as an individual,
like can this be collectivized?
Can this be brought forward so that more
people like,
you know,
do you take that leap of faith that fuck
me,
if we do get hundred 50 people together,
of course it's going to be problems,
challenges,
problems and fucking challenges.
Now we're not competing with perfection.
We compete with a defunct system that's
really causing a great deal of
negativity and problems.
What would happen if people did start to
try and create alternatives are to what
happened?
You'd be killed.
No,
I don't think.
You don't think so?
No code right out.
If you end right,
we're setting up a system,
hundred 50 people where this is our new
podcast experiment.
We're setting up a utopia.
Only when you become a threat and you
have to become a threat financially or
you have to become a threat militarily.
One of the things about these fucking
Waco type,
they always gathered guns did fuck
everybody's wives and they have a
pile of ammunition.
Then you become a threat,
David.
What's the stockpile of guns in the
fucking?
Everyone's saying,
oh,
I just focused on Jesus,
so Jesus rose,
right?
Once you become a threat,
and that's the only way violence is the
only real threat
to expound on those ideas and spread
those ideas.
It's controversial,
but I don't think anybody looks at it
and says,
you know what?
This motherfucker is going to take money
out of my bank account.
I think people were so engrossed in
their own life and their own progress,
their own path of conquering.
I don't think they think about it that
way unless you crossed them and unless
you.
Like you say,
you know what,
God dammit this Rupert Murdoch is
fucking up the world.
That I'm going to expose him and I'm
going to let the world.
Then you've created an issue.
Then you've gone into battle with a man
with unfathomable resources that tried.
That
didn't work out.
Done
bloody sick of all this.
You see his wife,
he's got a hot wife.
Cool.
CIS.
Amazing.
I love how stereotypes just play
themselves out over and over and over.
Donald Trump's wife.
I go,
that's what I like to see the same thing
over and over again.
Tapping.
I'm in pain.
I got to pee.
Go ahead man.
No worries.
Yeah,
I think.
I think we,
you know,
one of the things Mckenna said that
always resonated with me is that so many
people do the man's work for the man and
they're so worried about the
repercussions of being free or
expressing themselves or discussing
psychedelics.
They do the man's work for the man
by not by being scared and shackling
themselves and expressing yourself in a
way that makes sense.
You know,
like I think one of the things that's
most interesting about Mckenna's
lectures where he was in sort of the
infancy of the Internet where you did a
lot of them is he expressed himself in
a,
in a way that's kind of really similar
to like podcasts rants,
but way before their time.
He was doing it in front of these groups
of people and someone recorded it so he
would have these meetings,
you know,
that people come to hear him speak and
he would have these meetings and he
would,
a lot of times you would open up the
room for questions and he would just
sort of rant and you know,
he's a consummate consumer of cannabis,
so he's high as fuck.
And he's having these bizarre
conversations,
these rants rigs exploring these ideas
and he got better and better and better
at them all throughout these rants.
And when he's doing these,
he's essentially doing a podcast.
It takes a long time to hear.
He was.
Do you think of him just sort of a
modern secular profit?
Because if you sort of like,
if you've been into the comedy of Bill
Hicks and then you listen to terrence
Mckenna,
you can see like,
oh fuck,
he's clearly influenced.
The.
I found out about Mckenna
was to Hicks bit [inaudible] Hicks had
this bit about what he,
he said what Terence Mckenna would
describe as a heroic dose of mushrooms.
So I was like,
who the fuck is Terence Mckenna?
And this was,
you know,
the nineties when I heard this.
So I had seen Hicks live a couple times
for three or four times I guess in
Boston.
And um,
what was that?
It was amazing.
First Time I saw him,
it was an accident.
First Time I saw him I went to see some
comedians that were like local Boston
guys and Hicks had come in from out of
town and I don't know if he was supposed
to be there the next night or what it
was,
but no one was there to see him.
They didn't know who he was.
And he went up on stage and was just so
weird.
And he was doing this bit about tiffany
meeting Jimmy Hendrix.
At the mall,
you know,
that uh,
like this music that they're promoting
is pop culture,
bullshit music and,
and he was at the comedy connection in
Boston.
I saw him think I saw him there first
and I saw him at Nick's and a couple
other places.
But uh,
he was,
he was doing some new thing.
I was like,
okay,
this is a new kind of comedy.
This is like Sam Kinison,
but with much more of an emphasis on the
realization that the patterns were all
falling into whether it's pop culture
patterns or at these things are actually
detrimental that these things are,
they're foolish way to approach this
world.
This world is incredibly complex and we
could all look at it together.
And I was like,
well,
this is,
this is a new kind of comedy.
How is he going down in the booth?
Really good and really bad.
I saw him bomb horribly,
but bomb with grace that I've never
achieved.
He,
he bombed.
He didn't give a fuck about bombing.
I've never been able to do that.
He,
he bombed like a guy who almost knew the
future,
knew he was going to have some sort of
an impact on the culture and knew that
this was just a footnote in that
incredibly impactful experience on the
art form of standup comedy and also knew
that eventually he'd find his own
audience,
which he did not have at the time
because he was at a small comedy club.
Nick's comedy stop in Boston,
which is a couple hundred people.
And um,
there was a guy who went on before him
who was a real hack,
nice guy,
but just hacky,
hacky bullshit cop donut jokes,
that kind of shit.
Just everything you've already heard
before.
Nothing original.
And he was killing,
killing with others.
Simple stupid shit.
And then Hicks went on afterwards with
this,
like really bizarre interpretation of
modern civilization ever is like,
fuck this guy.
And people were getting up and leaving
in droves and uh,
kept going through the whole thing.
And me and Greg Fitzsimmons was there
and a bunch of other comedians watching
them bomb.
We were laughing our asses off.
So he was playing to the back of the
room,
the comedians that were still there
laughing.
We're laughing hard and support,
but people are getting up and giant
chunks and leaving at the end of the
show,
you know,
the show was whittled down from like 250
people to like 40 people in 15 or 20
comics.
That was all that was left and we were
howling laughing and he got offstage.
Like nothing happened.
He would not compromise.
Who's an interesting guy.
So then go on and then that's it.
That's what he kicks you off into the
Mckenna realm.
Yeah,
he,
he's one introduced me to Mckenna by
that joke.
Just by saying that.
And then in hearing Hicks's references,
you know,
he was,
there was a few other guys that he sort
of referenced their ideas.
Like Noam Chomsky was another one.
Like one of the things that Hicks was
famous for saying was actually a chomsky
line was that about the Iraq war,
that it's only really in a war when two
armies are fighting,
you know.
And that was,
like I said,
direct Chmielowski quote.
It is,
and it's a hicks.
Well He,
you know,
it's not,
I don't want,
I don't want to say it's plagiarism
because I bet if you asked him,
he would tell you it's a noam chomsky
quote,
but he was introducing that concept and
that idea to these people through the
world of standup comedy and then from
there he expanded on that with all of
his material about the Iraq war and the
all the new weapons that they're doing
and forming equipment.
I'm starting that shame bit.
Yeah.
So.
And I think you give him that because
it's so like the stuff he was doing was
so innovative and incredible and funny.
Lucky.
Like I sort of say you look to and say
you said Kennison or lenny bruce before
that,
like
what I've experienced of them and I'm
not by any means and authority.
He did like Bill Hicks did make it more
densely humorous.
Maybe not when you see him live on that,
but by the time he was recording
specialist and stuff.
Sure.
I also live A.
I've always thought that Bill Hicks was
extremely refined and honed.
What was neat.
It's like,
you know,
like you can see incarnations of the
same content many,
many times with him where he,
at least in the stuff that I saw because
I've only ever seen him know,
recorded.
He wasn't going out.
He wasn't like doing lots of spontaneity
and lots of luck.
It was like they were like beautiful,
very articular pieces of.
Yeah.
And sometimes they didn't even make
people laugh.
You know,
I watched it with his girl I was dating
at the time in like 19 or 23 ish,
something like that.
And she was like,
yeah,
he's not really funny,
but he's really fascinating to listen
to.
Like she didn't find like some of the
things he was saying were funny,
but I think that was also the revelation
show which you filmed in London,
which was one of those weird shows where
you're doing an hbo special and you have
one show ready go and there's some weird
pressure that's involved with that and
it doesn't necessarily always come off
loose and like the feeling that you see
him when he's at a club where he's
expressing himself in a much more
freeway.
I felt that he's a lot of his comedy as
high points.
Of course he's content came from his
ability to do characterization that you
do like a sort of a long bit that used
to like,
oh my God,
this guy is just hitting me with data.
But like when he died,
oh believe God created a in one day.
But those things,
it looks like he rushed it.
Rafiki doesn't let you off and then.
And then as well that the thing that
we're good.
I think that revelations was the first
thing that I ever saw of.
He's like when I was like was a kid,
but when he does the market in France,
you know,
like in one advertising mock and Kudos,
I couldn't,
you know,
I couldn't believe his sincerity.
I couldn't believe that someone would
hit you with that much heart.
Quit putting a dollar sign and every
damn thing on this planet.
But something like that.
Some of it.
So that was from the heart,
Huh?
Resonated.
Whenever someone,
something resonates and stays.
I mean,
it's also,
there's so much mythology involved in
him now because he's passed on and he
died young and we always sit back and
wonder like,
what would it be?
I liked that guy was alive today.
He didn't have the outlet then where
that's again,
now you can go back and look at a guy
like that because it's there and back
then you weren't ready to handle that.
Who's talking like,
I'm coming to comedy club.
I want to.
I want to laugh.
Yeah.
I to think tonight will Hicks Hicks was,
you know,
I don't know what you're saying.
So kennison opened the door for him
because he was one of the outlaws and
Kennison had a lot of bits that were
like that,
but they were more humor based than
point of view based like he had points
of view.
But the point of view had to be really
funny.
Whereas Hicks had a lot of points of
view.
There's like there's gotta be a way to
introduce these ideas into people in the
form of standup comedy that maybe not
even aren't that funny but are very
important.
Whereas Kennison was,
everything was,
I mean he had some ridiculously funny
bits and he did it in this totally
unapologetic way that I think Hicks kind
of absorbed and when I first saw Hicks
is one of the things he had a lot of
Kennison in him,
like we all have influences and when
we're starting out we like to hear other
comedians that you really love come out
of your own mouth,
almost like with the intonations and the
inflections and you almost kind of mimic
them in your delivery.
And Hicks did a lot of that.
When I first saw him,
he was doing a lot of Kennison and it
was interesting.
It was like this guy is clearly
influenced and.
Well,
one of the.
Okay.
You don't know whether or not he was
influenced by Kinesin or kinison was
influenced by Hex,
but most likely it's probably a little
bit of both,
but more Kennison than anything because
Kennison was much more successful
earlier on,
like several years before Hicks really
took off and was revolutionary.
When Kennison came on the scene.
He was completely revolutionary.
So I think him taking Hicks with him,
you know,
because they were a part of that Houston
group that originally expanded and then
came to la.
I think he just showed that there's,
there's just some unbilled undeniable
power and being that controversial but
on point
what startup is one of the original
American art form,
isn't it?
It's like there is precedent prior to
America.
Proprietor being in the United States
was not like that art form exist in the
same way.
Let's go gestures or just as Rava or
music call.
It didn't exist in that kind of way.
And in a,
in a manner like it's a very.
Podcasting is very natural medium for a
comedian because it grants you that long
form because I've always thought like
the,
you know,
the more it can be that the more
truthful you are and the more articulate
become,
the more you reduce your audience.
You know,
when you think of like he liked hitting
up rooms have 2,500 people or 5,000,
you know,
arena gigs.
Like if you want to go in the white in
there with fucking Noam Chomsky,
bloody quotes
finished.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You got to have some way to connect
those things with humor bound.
Almost like scaffolding in between
ideas.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because you've got that.
That's the thing I think about sort of
like keeping the ball above a certain
level and in a way this medium,
your are relief that,
that you are allowed.
It's like,
oh,
sit back for awhile.
Listen for ages.
But they,
the,
the aspect of comedy that I think is so
important of authenticity,
you know when people,
when you are a startup comic,
people go,
Oh,
you got to find your voice.
You got to find your authenticity in
like you were saying that you hear the
musicality of Comedians you admire in
your voice that like when you're doing
five minutes or or 10,
it's extremely difficult,
isn't it?
To become robust enough with that.
But here I guess you get to really
explore what you are authentically in a
kind of a long safe form,
especially 10 minutes.
That's those,
those little short sets you do it.
So those are just,
you know,
me,
you can get a bid out or a series of
funny things that you can say,
but as far as like any real depth and
part of what comes out that's really
funny is like if you watch someone like
Jim,
part of like what his comedy is like,
you'll understand after you see him for
15 or 20 minutes,
this is how he makes fun of things.
This is his personality.
So you kind of get his vibe and then
another subject comes up and you're
laughing before he even starts talking
about it because you're kind of
following where he's going to take this.
Yeah.
You've signed up to.
I'll enjoy this now.
Yeah.
You're tuned into his perspective.
Kinison was a huge influence.
Yeah.
I loved Kennison.
He was the hands down and he was
revolutionary.
It was like seeing Metallica for the
first time.
Like what would lead the way these
people reacting?
I never saw a,
uh,
an audience of comedy audience.
He made them.
He made them almost want to go in a
marsh pit and to,
to.
No,
I don't think Carlin would dance around
being Catholic and and kind of expose
things but not.
I mean Kennison comes out and he just in
a biblical way,
I thought it.
My mom tried to make me go to church and
it made me a good person.
I learned more about biblical to and
just how common sense wise listening to
him.
He made me think about it.
He come out and yet Jesus was never
married.
No wife is going to buy the and he'd go
into this whole thing about he leaves on
a Fridays with 10 of his friends.
His wife has passed.
Know where's the,
where's all those losers that call
themselves disciples?
Everyone that says I believe,
I believe we put up feed.
I had sat down with hopefully do the
common sense of this is why doesn't
anyone talk about the common sense of
this?
He just put it balls out there.
He can get away with it because he was a
preacher and he knew the Bible.
He knew everything about it and he would
sit there and he comes home on Monday,
looks like shit is dirt all over his
face and he sees his cross out on the
lawn and she's like way Mr
as well.
Another one I was dad
decomposer.
I'm in the spiritual world.
I got to get back a sheet.
I don't know where I began,
and then he went on this whole thing
about,
oh,
they doctored this whole last supper.
Jesus me,
am I gonna am I gonna betray you?
And he'd say,
Oh,
sock my dad,
you know,
fuck you.
I
will say drink of this blood.
And
just the common,
just he may,
he dumbed it down to an made me really
think about that one.
Yeah.
This is also,
like we said about Metallica,
the force of his delivery.
Yes.
Unprecedented.
And no one had yelled out punchlines
before.
The way he did it.
He married?
Yeah.
You were married and I hung back to you.
Good.
Remember this face.
No one,
no one came at you like that,
but it was.
It was more than shtick.
It was freaking hilarious and it made a
lot of sense whenever,
whatever.
Who did talk about the devil,
the devil coming down teaching you.
It was,
it was sick.
I remember her talking about,
well,
you said becoming famous because you're
fucking heart is you finished your show.
He trying to stay marriage.
It comes up in Australia.
No,
ever.
No.
Two fingers in your as and me and my
friends are,
well,
fuck,
fuck you to your can even fog and breath
in.
Then he'd go home to your wife.
No one will ever know or like,
uh,
you know,
I've married,
she's on her period and we're going,
we're in the middle of a really
difficult time,
but thank you.
Thanks.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a real wild man.
He was like,
he introduced rock and roll
sensibilities to cry.
That's what I was attracted to.
That whole rock,
crazy loud energy.
Well,
he was also so different than everything
else at the time,
which was like the roll your sleeves up,
you know?
Did she ever notice,
you know,
ever noticed how come when you get a cup
of coffee?
There were no,
there was this sort of observational
comedy boom back then and he came along,
which is roaring monster.
His first bit ever on tv ever I think
was the African,
which was huge here,
like you please help these poor children
help these children
and he comes out and he's gone and I'm
sick and tired of seeing these
commercials when I try to make you feel
guilty.
You're sitting there watching how can
you sit there and your air condition
heat covered full,
a full kind of sick,
fuck God.
Give him a dollar and then he goes into
the whole thing.
Don't send them another thing.
They live in fucking don't send them
money.
So someone like me going to go there.
I've come here,
we came here 500 miles and we realized
we wouldn't have to travel this far.
People
taste it,
but it's going to be 100 years from now.
Fucking sand deserts in America too,
which is don't live in hall.
Chad's got the drive
and what was one of the best examples of
like,
people always like,
this is a fucking trend now,
but good comedy should always punch up a
comedy shows,
punch out bullshit.
Bullshit,
bullshit.
Nonsense.
Comedy should be comedy.
It's just like rap music or fucking
gangster movies.
It's indecipherable.
You cannot decide what's funny,
what's not funny,
and that is one of the best examples of
it.
That African bit,
Ugh,
huge change.
My like he.
It's simple.
It's funny,
it's a real,
it's a real topic.
And I actually sat there and thought it
went,
why don't,
why are they living in a fucking desert?
A retarded,
like what's,
why can't they move?
This is stupid.
I don't get this.
Why don't you help them?
You're right next to him.
Don't feed them yet,
right?
Goddamn blanket.
It's not ready yet.
We skied is
such a great bit and again,
a great bit if it.
If someone did it in 2016,
but in the 84 revolutionary yeah,
85 maybe.
Maybe it'd be fucking revolutionary.
It's releasing you from the sanctimony.
There's two.
So much sanctum into your way down and
you know,
able to have an authentic reaction.
There's so much of yourself that you are
oppressing and it takes him and you see
that again through tend to architects
conversation.
We add that there.
Trickster,
the role of the tricks that I like that
comes up in native American meth is like
a coyote or the rave and or they say
that like even Christ is a tricks there
in moments in the bottle of these people
that I am,
that's not reality anymore,
other than that's a tricks the function
to go like,
you know,
you know that there's a prescribed way
that you're supposed to respond to that,
uh,
African commercial.
Well look,
there's this alternative way of
responding to it and to present it
comedically,
so freed me.
You freed me from reality is like an
unchanging.
And you know what's interesting about
him?
Did you ever read his brother's book?
Brother Sam.
His brother wrote a great book of Mine,
Sam,
and one of the things that he said is
Sam's like emergence of who he is.
He came out of a car accident.
He got hit by a truck when he was a
little kid and it changed his
personality,
radically hit a serious head injury.
You got knocked the fuck out and came
back fearless,
and that's a.
that's a common thing.
Impulsiveness,
fearlessness and rage.
These are con,
the constant themes that come out of
head trauma,
so it's interesting like one of the most
important figures in the history of
standup comedy might have literally been
birthed because of trauma,
like physical brain trauma that's barely
and I never heard the
brain damaged pioneer for that head
injury.
Same would never have been discussed.
City was a different person like before
that he was like quiet and shy and a
normal kid and then Bam,
he gets hit by a car,
fucked up,
put in the hospital.
The whole deal comes out of that.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He just tastes deaths.
I don't think that's it.
I still think it's a steal because a
pretty chat,
right?
Yeah.
Like what the fuck's he doing?
Good.
I had trauma drew in the moment,
but it was.
That was how we deliver
up
Jesus.
He had this explosive dynamic delivery
and I mean I don't want to attribute all
of it to to the head trauma because
obviously there was some genius
involvement is creativity.
You definitely blew my I.
I'm.
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
It's not a negative thing.
Look,
I've.
I've dealt with a lot of brain trauma
because I know a lot of people that have
gotten fucked up from fighting.
You know,
it's there's a real thing that happens
to people and you,
you hear about all the time when they do
these shows on nfl players who become
explosive and they,
they get crazy and impulsive and they
get very violent and some of that has to
do with repeated trauma to the head.
Well,
just one event,
one car accident,
one thing like that can literally change
your personality because it's a very
fragile dynamic of synapses and
personality.
Neurochemicals.
The brain's actual like the flow of
chemicals of neurochemistry and the
physical body itself and the way your
personality manifests itself.
All those things are directly connected
and an event like what happened to Sam
Kennison literally reshaped in art form.
Well,
about 10 people to get head trauma and
suddenly can speak perfect French.
Have you seen them on the Internet a
lot?
Yeah.
They knocked over the nuts.
Come back with perfect French.
It's a common phenomenon and it can be
checked out online anytime.
Is that true?
They get really good at math.
They only speak French.
Does someone have to teach them from
mice with the risk little head trauma.
The downside is you've said he might
come back to the stream and the
aggressive or you might have a headache
forever.
It's also possible to set a lot easier
and quicker.
It's much quicker satisfaction and
getting them stupid books.
I don't have patience for them.
Books,
foreign accent syndrome.
Accent.
I'm a rare creatures.
Develop appears to
be a foreign accent.
Chinese teacher stroke.
Speaking English.
What about that?
How about that?
But it's the daily mail.
They might have just made that up.
So we'll click on it right now.
Motherfuckers,
um,
I dunno because I do know we have to end
this though.
Unfortunately
checking for 23 hours and 20 minutes.
I don't think I'm going to adjust to the
girlfriend.
And stuff,
and be a normal person.
You're going to have to continue to keep
doing podcasts.
It's four slash 20.
What time do we come in here?
Jim and I had been here since 10:00 AM.
Five hours.
Six hours.
Yeah.
You and I've been doing this for six
calls to
listen.
Then if you're ever in here again,
you've got an open invitation.
Of course.
You know you have an open invitation
anytime,
man,
please.
We've got to do this more often and
really.
Thanks man.
Alright,
you fucks.
That's it.
I hope you enjoyed it.
My mind.
Wow.
That was.